Hey everybody, welcome to the podcast.
My guest today is Dr. Andrew Huberman.
Andrew is a neuroscientist.
He's a Neurobiology Professor at Stanford Medical School
and McKnight Foundation and Pew Foundation Fellow
and the founder of Huberman Lab, where he's involved
in all kinds of really amazing breakthrough research
on brain function, brain plasticity and brain regeneration.
His work has been published in top journals like Nature.
He's been featured in publications
like Time, Scientific America and the BBC.
And he's here today to discuss the brain,
to discuss growth mindset, how to focus,
how to navigate the stressful times and many other subjects.
It's an incredible conversation.
I think you guys are gonna enjoy it.
I appreciate you watching
make sure to hit that subscribe button
and without further ado, this is me
and Dr. Andrew Huberman.
First of all, thanks for doing this.
I appreciate you coming out.
Yeah, my pleasure.
Long time coming.
I'm glad we're doing it in person-
Likewise.
And not remotely.
And I think what I wanna do is start with your origin story,
because you're a very,
it's your path is very unlikely,
your path to becoming a scientist.
And I think it actually also kind of contextualizes
some of the things that I wanna talk about with you today.
So maybe start there.
Sure, so on the one hand, you know,
maybe I was faded to become a scientist.
I guess the two things that are relevant there
are I always loved animals
and I've always been obsessed with animal behavior.
Like just could watch Cousteau shows growing up, you know
underwater life or animals hunting, animals doing anything.
It's just so fascinating to me because I'm, I think even
at a really young age, I've always just been intrigued
in sort of what drives different animals to behave
in the way they do and how body form matches to,
I didn't know what it was,
but brains and how that all works.
So I've always been obsessed with animals.
And then my dad's a scientist, so he's a physicist.
It was really early in chaos theory.
And so growing up in our home, you know, we had scientists
over for dinner and graduate students would come over
for barbecues and things like that.
Is he a Stanford professor?
Yeah, he was at Stanford.
He was mostly at Xerox Park, which is kind of famous
if you read the Steve Jobs book is for the, yeah.
The development of the gooey interface
the graphical user interface
and sort of early days of the computer.
So he had a lab there and he had a lab in applied physics
at Stanford and something called symbolic systems
which is a Stanford degree
in kind of ecology and computation, that kind of thing.
So I grew up in this family where science was very prominent
and we had lots of discussions
in our home that I would overhear
and I didn't understand about physics and we'd spend summers
at the Aspen Center for Physics, which was like-
Good times.
Yeah, so, you know,
and we were, and to be clear, you know,
you hear the word Aspen, you know,
we were a middle-class family
but they have this Aspen Center for Physics.
So the Feynman, you know, Richard Feynman was there,
Murray Gell-mann,
like all these luminaries of physics, Peter Carruthers.
And my dad was really good at telling me the stories
about these guys and then I'd always wanna meet them.
And it was mostly guys back then,
there weren't many women in physics.
So I, you know, I was kind of immersed in science
from a young age, but right about age 13,
my parents split up.
And he moved overseas, he moved to Denmark
and my mom was really struggling with the breakup
and I wasn't in contact with him anymore.
So I had this really unusual childhood where, you know,
we didn't talk about sports, we talked about science,
and I had this close relationship with science
and the people around science
but then all of a sudden the structure around family
like instead of dinners together every night,
it was just like me and my mom
and I was an adolescent, I was hitting puberty.
So, you know, there was bound to be some shifts
in my world landscape and internal landscape anyway.
But basically what happened was, I stopped
really paying attention to school.
And I got really heavily into skateboarding
and the kind of punk rock music.
And I found my pack or my community
through like packing community of kids
that also just were kind of parentless.
So this was like late 80s, early 90s.
And so at a pretty young age, I started taking the,
I grew up in Palo Alto.
I was actually born at Stanford Hospital.
I started taking the seven F bus up to San Francisco
and hanging around in Embarcadero.
For the skateboarders out there, the Lizards,
this is the the now famous EMB crowd.
So this was the birth of a huge movement
of skateboarders that became professionals.
Like, so you'd see the young Danny Way
would come through town and you had Rob Dyrdek.
I remember when he came through.
So all these names that eventually became popular
during the kind of X games era and the,
but at that time it was really underground.
And so it was this pack of maybe a hundred guys
and it was run like a little city and it was chaos.
It was like there was fights,
and there was drinking and there was lawlessness,
there was also a lot of amazing skateboarding
and there were a lot of amazing people.
And there were some older guys,
like one in particular, a very famous skateboarder,
is this kid, Mike Carroll,
his older brother was kind of like the older brother
to everybody, kind of kept us all in check.
So it had its own unique organization.
And it's actually interesting
'cause the same thing was happening at that time
in Washington Square Park in New York,
and at Love Park in Philadelphia, there were all these
like communities of kids that were basically parentless.
And so in that time I saw some interesting things.
First of all, I learned what it was to be parentless.
Growing up in Palo Alto,
it was like soccer games and AYSO and you know,
swim club and all of a sudden I realized, you know,
I don't have to be home at any particular time,
or, you know, none of these kids are going to school.
And so we all, it was kind of a big group of truants.
And it was interesting because it gave me a perspective
that I had never had in Palo Alto.
And I was drifting further and further away
from any kind of academic rigor.
I think I would go to school every once in a while.
What's mom doing?
Does she have any idea
that you're going up to the city every day?
So she was totally checked out.
You know, I think she was just devastated
by a bunch of things that were happening
and she lapsed into a pretty serious depression.
And then in that community, what was interesting is,
I started seeing that, you know, some guys were clearly
faded to becoming professional skateboarders.
They were really good at it.
I just wanna say for full disclosure,
I was not particularly good.
I kept getting injured.
I just, I was not faded to be, you know, exceptional
or very good at it, but I love the comradery
and I love the community, but I also noticed that, you know,
some people were drinking all day and other people got
into hard drugs and people started to, you know,
some of the dysfunction really started to show up.
Yeah, the fracture.
Begins.
Exactly, and so,
and I started seeing that, lot, a lot more violence.
You know, people start getting their girlfriends pregnant.
They didn't have money to support those kids.
You know, it started becoming apparent to me
that there was a lot of dysfunction
as well as a lot of incredible people in that community.
And so about that time, I got a girlfriend,
and the other thing was I got removed from high school.
So I went to kind of the famed/infamous high school
in Palo Alto, Gunn High School.
Oh, you went to Gunn.
I went to Gunn, which is famous because it's the,
one of the most academically rigorous schools
in the country, maybe the planet,
people moved to the area just to send their kids there.
But it also has this very complicated reputations
of the highest suicide rate of any school in the country.
The New York Times has written about this.
So, you know, I would come to school every once in a while
but I could tell you far more about the curbs
in the front of the Gunn High School parking lot
than I could about anything that I learned at Gunn.
So when they say they, you were removed,
I mean, you got, you were expelled.
No, I basically, they just said,
you need to either start coming to school or, you know-
You're done.
Or you're done.
So I got shifted to another high school
and that was same story.
It was just was, it was a mess, it just fell apart.
And so at one point I was brought in, I have a kind
of vague recollection of this, but I was brought in
to have a discussion with a school counselor.
And I don't think I've ever told this story before.
And there was someone sitting in the corner,
this guy was sitting in the corner
and he didn't introduce himself.
And pretty soon I realized when I was like,
I think they're gonna take me away.
Like I started realized, 'cause they realized my mom
wasn't really able to control me.
Wasn't really in a place to support me at that time.
And that's what they did.
They took me away.
They took me into a place up the peninsula,
which was not a jail and it wasn't a hospital.
It was just sort of a place where they put kids
that were-
Like some kind of
GV warehousing situation?
Yeah, a lot of psychologists,
lot of locks on doors, lot of,
lot of kids that, there were 12 of us in there
at any one time, it was locked down.
And the first night there,
I remember I had a roommate who was like really
into cutting on himself, that kind of thing.
And he told me, he was like, "Look, if you just
do what they say here, you'll be outta here in like a month.
And if you don't, you're gonna be here a very long time."
And I remember being pretty frightened for the first time.
And at that point I was like,
oh my goodness, like, this is bad.
You know, like, this is bad.
I'm a long way.
It's so hard for me
to imagine.
I know, I know.
This given you know, who you are and what you do now.
I know and you know, and it was literally like the kind
of one phone call a day kind of thing.
So actually I called I was skateboarding for a company
in San Francisco.
I think they put me on out of sympathy
and I called this guy up and I said, "Look, I've, you know,
they locked me up, I don't know what to do.
Can you help me?"
And he get, and I'll never forget,
I wanna say his name because you're the most normal guy
I know.
Well, he's like-
The least likely of that crowd.
Exactly.
For that to happen.
So, in any event, I was permitted to go back to school
eventually, provided that I went to therapy.
And so I started going to weekly therapy
which in the early 90s was kind of a weird thing.
You would, wouldn't admit it to your friends
but tweets skateboard around Stanford campus.
I was doing my thing and then twice a week
I would go in and see this therapist.
He's a remarkable guy because A,
he had deep training in the mind, right?
And we started talking about what was going on.
And he really picked up on the fact
that there was essentially no structure,
no home life for me, but that I had a strong drive,
and I was really interested in learning.
I mean, I was, I was enthusiastic and motivated enough to,
you know, skateboard as hard as I could,
even though I wasn't gonna go anywhere with it.
So at that point, and the fact that I had a girlfriend,
I started looking for something that I could do.
And I started at one point
I thought I'd join the fire service,
'cause it seemed like the comradery was good.
At that point, I started strengthening my body a bit
because I didn't wanna keep getting hurt.
So I started running, I started lifting weights,
a football coach at Gunn actually turned me on to fitness.
It's actually an interesting guy.
He wrote the script for that movie "Mr. Mom,"
Oh my God.
Yeah, because his wife bet him
that he couldn't do what she could do,
which was stay home with the kids.
And he was this big strong football coach.
And so he made her a bet and he lost.
And so he wrote that script Michael Keaton played the, yeah.
So he taught me, he was like, look, you know
you can't even do a pull up.
You need to start doing your pull-ups and you start running
you know, and he said, the fire service
might be good for you.
So, I was spinning out, but there were people
that were willing to kind of, you know,
point me in the right direction.
So what ended up happening was my high school girlfriend
went off to college and I didn't, you know,
I didn't know what I was gonna do.
So I actually went and I lived in the parking lot
outside her dormitory. I just wanted to be near her.
She was my family at that point.
A college locally or?
She was at UC Santa Barbara.
So you just drove down and-
I just drove down and I just camped out in the parking lot
and people, and I was starting to get into some martial arts
and Thai boxing then.
So I think I was teaching some Thai boxing,
self-defense stuff on campus and doing this kind of thing.
And by the end of that year, I realized
that I should probably apply to college.
So I applied to UCSP and somehow I got in,
Lord knows how I got in.
I did, 'cause I did eventually graduate high school, barely.
Got in, and then after a year I just completely flailed it.
You know, I wasn't going to class.
I was getting into fights, a lot of that kind of mischief
and kind of wildness was still in me.
And what ended up happening was,
I got into a physical altercation on July 4th, 1994
with like a bunch of guys.
And at the end of that, I walked back to the place
I was staying, and of course I wasn't paying rent
because I had learned in those years,
like you can just squat in an empty house.
So, you know, it's Isla Vista California, you know?
So I was really running wild and went back
and just I realized I was like, this picture is really bad.
You know, at some point,
this isn't gonna be like a kid who had some problems,
this is gonna be,
truly.
It's not cute anymore.
It's not cute anymore
And no one,
no one's gonna make excuses about your upbringing
or the lack of parenting.
It just becomes, you just, you're gonna end up
being a ward of the state.
I mean, you were, it sounds like you were,
you were almost a feral animal.
Totally feral.
Actually, and I have some close friends
that's how they they referred to me, that feral.
And it's funny even to this day, I mean,
I'll get to where this eventually took me.
But even to this day, when I go into a home
where it's clearly like a loving home
where there's kids are happy
and there's good food and it's warm and cozy
I always feel this thing like, wow, like amazing.
Like I sort of wanna be adopted by them immediately,
but you know, I'm 45 years old
so that's not appropriate at this age.
What's so interesting,
I keep thinking about David Epstein's book "Range."
Did you read this book?
Which is basically this thesis
that some of the most successful people are not,
you know, we suspect that, you know,
the great talents of the world across all disciplines
are the people who discover their passion at an early age
and practice it voraciously for many, many, many years.
But in fact, it's people more like yourself,
who've dabbled in all different kinds of things
who end up being ultimately, you know,
the most proficient at their selected skillset.
And when I look at your experience,
I see trauma, I see adventure,
I see, you know, all these obstacles that you've had to face
and overcome and manage on your own essentially, right?
And all of those really informed perfectly
the things that you're interested in
and what you explore today in your lab.
Yeah, it really did.
You know, I think that I'm so grateful for those years.
I wouldn't wish them on any kid,
because I think having a secure, loving environment
at home is so key.
And, you know, I should say about a third of the kids
that I grew up with in that environment,
that whole skateboarding, punk rock culture,
about a third have gone on to found companies
or professional skateboarders,
about a third just kind of drifted off
and about a third are dead or incarcerated.
You know, a huge number.
And so there's real value in having a support system,
that's clear, but it exposed me
to all these things like addictions, schizophrenia, rage,
like all these incredible elements.
Like I was never really into drinking and drugs.
I could drink or not drink.
It just wasn't, I wasn't drawn to it, but other people
they took one sip and it was like, that was their thing.
It was like the magic elixir for them.
And so, you know, I was observing what was happening.
And then after that, you know, that July 4th '94 incident
was, I realized this is it, you know, it's now or never.
It really was one of those moments.
You know, you hear about those moments
but it was me realizing I'm living in this squat
where I've got a pet ferret.
My girlfriend's gone, she broke up with me.
She was smart enough to break up with me, you know,
I'm getting in fights, I'm working at a bagel shop.
I'm barely making ends meet.
And at that point I just made the decision.
I just said, okay, look,
I'm not gonna be a professional athlete.
I think I'm pretty good at memorizing things.
I think I have an interest in people,
I'm going to just decide, I just decided to do school.
I decided that was the, that was the track.
And so like, some people pick the military
because it's like, if you know what to expect
at least in terms of the, you know,
the passages that you're gonna go through.
And for me that was school.
And so I had decided, get back in school.
I moved into a studio apartment by myself.
I quit partying completely, I didn't go to parties.
I got really serious about fitness.
So I just started running and lifting weights and I studied.
You went like Henry Rollins style.
I did.
Yeah.
It's a lot of self-awareness
you know, I mean, people go into the military
because on some level, I mean,
some people do because they're, there's some yearning
for having that structure imposed upon their lives.
But you constructed that kind of structure for yourself.
Yeah, I think I was really afraid.
I think I was like, you know, and I and these days,
you know, 'cause of my lab studies fear
and I get into this whole thing around mindsets
and people always ask me like,
is it better to do something from a place of love or fear?
Like depends.
And at that point, fear was the best motivator for me.
And I just basically worked like crazy.
And it's interesting because I didn't have a mentor
or someone to bring me to that.
But once I started doing that, you know,
there was one professor in particular who took note,
he was like, "Oh, you know,
you seem really interested in this stuff."
And I was like, yeah, 'cause he was teaching me
about depression, schizophrenia, neuro-chemicals.
I thought, I was totally turned on
by the world of neuroscience.
It didn't, it wasn't even called neuroscience back then.
But this one guy, Harry Carlisle
he was teaching me about thermal regulation
and how the brain works and how receptors
in the skin relate to perceptions in the mind.
And he also had a deep sensitivity to mental disease.
And I'd seen a lot of that, you know,
I'd seen a lot of depression and anxiety in my own family.
I had had a friend commit suicide.
Another friend becomes schizophrenic.
I think he's still walking the mission district
of San Francisco now.
Seeing some friends become addicts.
And so here was someone explaining that there's actually
an underlying basis for this.
And I just poured myself into it.
Is that the same guy who, you know,
would smoke underneath the vacuum hood and stuff like that?
Like a bit of an (indistinct).
Yeah, he was amazing.
So he was a favorite teacher of many students,
but if you could get into his lab
then you were kind of one of the chosen ones I guess.
He's like the perfect mentor at the perfect time for you.
Yeah, so he used to drink coffee in lab
which you're not supposed to do.
He's just smoke cigarettes in lab in the fume hood.
And they used to come and yell at him
and he would do it anyway.
And I thought, you know, this guy
he doesn't even know what it is, but you know,
he's a punk rocker and he doesn't even know.
And so, you know,
he gave me an opportunity to work in his lab.
And at some point he told me, if you go to graduate school
they'll actually pay you to do science.
And what ended up happening at that point
was I hit a brick wall because I was,
I had a lot of resentment toward my dad.
I felt, you know, here's my dad.
He was a scientist, he had, you know,
left us all this kind of thing.
And I realized if I didn't do this,
if I didn't take this opportunity,
it was going to be the most foolish thing ever.
You know, what am I gonna do to spite my, you know,
my parents, you know, I was 20 years old at that point.
So I just made the decision.
I'm gonna get a PhD and become a professor.
I'm going to get tenure and be like this guy, you know
this guy who has looked like he had a pretty good life
to me, and so that's pretty much how I spent the, you know
the last 25 years of my life is doing experiments.
It worked out.
It worked out, is it, a lot of work,
I mean, I didn't have the power of concentration.
I hadn't read all the good books that Gunn High School
students read growing up.
I had to learn how to speak properly.
I learned how to, learn how to think properly
and really learn how to commit to something
that was very linear and at times was very painful.
And I went to some pretty extreme things.
I, you know, I actually used to set a timer
and I wouldn't allow myself to get out of the chair
until I was, the timer went off.
So, and I would experience extreme agitation
but over time I got pretty good.
And now I can do long stints of work without any breaks.
And yeah, it worked out.
It developed that neuroplasticity
in your favor, ultimately.
You're always a reader though, right?
I loved books.
So I would, you know, I would hide
in the tower books section in the evenings
and I would read everything about fitness, psychology,
anything I could, I've always devoured information.
My favorite book when I was a kid was the "Encyclopedia,"
or the "Guinness Book of World Records."
So I was like, when I was a little kid,
I'd walk around the Aspen Center for Physics.
And I would tell anyone, I didn't even ask them,
if they want to hear about like the,
what's the world's smallest ethereum mammal.
You know, I would like, it could tell you all these facts
that were kind of meaningless at the time,
but I've always been fascinated
by the inventory of different animals on the planet
and their different behaviors.
And so yeah, voracious reader and still now.
I love, I love information.
Well, as a neuroscientist, I mean,
you're your own patient.
I mean, the fact that you were able to, you know,
turn your life around in such a dramatic fashion
and do it essentially through sheer will and you know
setting up practices that would feel you,
you in that right direction,
and then being available when those mentors
showed up from the, from the, you know,
the early therapist, sounds like that guy
almost saved your life, right?
He absolutely saved my life.
He gave me the book, "Wherever You Go, There You Are"
the Jon Kabat-Zinn book.
And he said, no pressure, but if you can develop
a mindfulness practice where you can sit still
for like 10 minutes a day, it'll serve you very well.
So I started doing that.
Like he could've, he could've told me to hang out
of a window by my ankles, I would have done it.
I think there was a, there was a self preservation thing
was kicking in for me.
So I got very interested in mindfulness meditation.
He also, it was, I think, quite smart in saying,
look there's a whole world of psychedelic drugs
that are powerful in influencing the mind.
He said, "If you're going to explore those,
wait until your brain has already developed,"
which I think is a controversial statement in and of itself.
He, so he actively discouraged me to go down that path,
which I think was the right thing,
given I was a minor, you know,
and nowadays there's all this discussion now
about psychedelics and their power.
And I think they are very interesting compounds
but he really steered me towards behavioral practices.
Like what could I do each day from waking up
to going to sleep that would serve my mental health
and my productivity well.
I owe him a tremendous amount.
And especially because he wasn't just
in the psychoanalytic theory,
he also was like cognitive behavioral.
He understood the power of practices
not just discussing issues.
Yeah, to begin a meditation practice at that age
in the mid 90s, that's pretty radical.
Yeah, I felt it was funny 'cause I thought
if I didn't sit in the lotus position
like I wasn't doing it properly, you know,
back then there was all this stuff around,
it was very mystical and in my family
'cause my dad's very conservative
and my mom was a little bit more of a free spirit.
I was taught that anything that related to hippie culture
was doomed to fail and cause problems.
And then anything that was related
to like conservative culture was faded
to advance the progress of humanity.
It turned out neither one was true, of course.
So I, but I needed people to push me in those directions,
lift weights, run, meditate,
do your schoolwork, do your homework.
And so I think I, you know, now I have a good relationship
with my parents, but I think I had to go out
into the world and find those, you know, sort of paternal
and maternal figures because they weren't in my home.
I needed to find those.
Do you look back on your upbringing with gratitude?
Like how do you reflect on that experience
and how it informs how you think about what you do now?
I'm immensely grateful for it because you know,
where I'm at today is, you know, my lab works on a number
of issues related, you know, sort of hardcore neurobiology
of regenerating the brain, you know, trying to fix,
basically cure blindness and repair visual systems,
but also things related to, you know, fear, courage,
mindset, stress, anxiety, trauma, et cetera.
And the early seed of seeing how science is done,
definitely gave me an advantage.
I won't lie, you know, I seeing how scientists interact
and behave and understanding that they are just people.
'Cause a lot of what was discussed in my home was
about the people, not just the science they do,
that really gave me an advantage.
And then seeing all that dysfunction and realizing
that the human animal is amazing at making plans,
at modifying its brain if it wants to, but the human brain
and the human animal are also dreadfully bad
at doing what's best for us.
Because of this, what I think it comes down to is the fact
that our reward systems are not designed
for things that are just good for us.
They're designed for things that optimize the progression
of our species, but they're also, they will grab on to
and ratchet into any behavior that makes us feel good.
And so the human brain is really not optimized
for making best choices.
And so, those years of seeing all that.
I could testify to that.
Yeah, it's and it's, I wouldn't trade those years
for anything.
And I still have great friends in that community.
I mean, I think, you know, any, had I joined
a different community, I would have found the right people
as well, but to be with a, you know, a huge pack
of feral kids at that age
and to see the function and dysfunction
and also it was wild, it was a lot of fun.
I can imagine.
It was a lot of fun.
That's a whole set of stories
for another time.
Did you see that movie,
"Mid 90s?"
"Mid 90s" and the movie "Kids", the Larry Clark movie.
When I saw that movie, first of all, I had a lot
of friends that were in that movie
'cause he used actual skateboarders.
In "Kids?"
Yeah, I actually knew a couple of those kids
and you know, it's a movie, but there are a lot of things
about that movie they're very accurate.
And when I saw that movie
I was like, yeah, that's like right.
Pretty much a day in the life in Washington Square Park.
And you know, I mean it was a little extreme on some end
but you didn't know where you're gonna end up each night.
And that was a unique experience, you know?
So yeah, and "Mid 90s" was really good.
I think it captured the essence of what it is to be a kid
that's just looking for some group of people to join.
And skateboard is a unique sport because you get young kids
and grown men and now women and girls do it as well.
It didn't happen so much then, but now there are a lot
of great, awesome skateboarders that are female
but they're all hanging out together.
You wouldn't find that in soccer.
You're not gonna get little kids playing with grown men.
So you get exposed to a lot 'cause everyone's
at develop, different developmental stages.
But yeah, it was an amazing thing.
I wouldn't change it for anything.
Cool, well, let's segue into talking about the brain
and maybe we could start with, you know,
how you think about the brain specifically?
Like, what is the brain, what does it do?
What does it not do?
You know, it helps us survive.
It's our portal into trying to make sense of the world.
Like what's the starting point
in the discussion around the brain?
Yeah, so the brain and nervous system, which
so it's like brain spinal cord connections
with the body and back in.
I don't distinguish between brain and mind.
I think that's like an 80s discussion or earlier.
And I think it would take us down the wrong track.
So brain or mind to me is interchangeable.
Mind, body, is kind of interchangeable
because the brain is connected to the body
and the body is connected to the brain, right?
If I, you know, pinprick my hand and it hurts
my brain registers it where it happens
it's kind of an irrelevant discussion.
I think we really need to just appreciate
that the nervous system is designed
to orchestrate all the processes in the body
not just thinking and not just behavior
and really can be divided into five things.
So there's sensation and sensation is really bound
or restricted by the receptors in the body.
So receptors in the eye that perceive photons, light energy
per se, receptors in the skin that perceive pressure
you know, touch receptors, smell, taste, hearing, et cetera.
And the interesting thing about sensation and the fact
that the nervous system needs to pay attention
to sensation is it's non-negotiable.
The nervous system of humans is designed
to extract physical phenomenon from the universe
that are non-negotiable, photons of light.
I can't see in the infrared with my eyes
and I can't see ultraviolet light with my eyes.
And I can't perceive that
because I don't have the receptors for it.
So, you know, other animals can perceive
some of those things
but that leads us to the next thing, which is perception
which is which sensations are you paying attention to.
So all the time you're sensing things like right now
your feet are sensing the contact with your shoes,
but you're not thinking about it until I say that.
And then you shift your perception.
So perception is like the spotlight.
So the brain wants to constantly bring in sensation.
It's non-negotiable what's coming in.
It's just dependent on your environment
Perception is negotiable, you can control that.
'Cause I just said shoes
and you thought about your feet and there you are.
Then there are feelings which can be a little bit nebulous
but feelings are a link between our emotion
and generally invokes the body,
sensations in the body and concepts in the mind
and what those sensations are about.
That's really what emotions are.
Animals definitely experience them.
I'm kind of appalled to think that 10 years ago
people like, do animals have emotions?
Of course they have emotions, right?
Because those are bodily sensations merged
with some perceptions, so of course they do.
And then there's thoughts and thoughts are interesting
because thoughts happen spontaneously.
Think about like a web browser
that's constantly giving you pop-ups
but thoughts can also be deliberate.
So you and I can decide right now that we're gonna think
about a plan for something or we're gonna think
about what's going on in the world.
So thoughts happen spontaneously and they can be deliberate.
And then the final thing is behaviors and actions.
So the nervous system is responsible for sensation,
perception, feelings, thoughts, and behaviors.
And what's interesting,
we start to think about that as you're like, okay
that's a lot, but what is the nervous system
really trying to accomplish?
Like on any given day or at any moment,
what's it trying to accomplish?
And it's really trying to accomplish one thing
which is to take perceptions of the outside world
and merge those with perceptions of the inside world
what we call interoception and to link those in a way
that's operating on an environment in the appropriate way.
So what do I mean by that?
So if I'm feeling anxious,
and I'm in a very calm environment, I'm gonna perceive
that rapid heart rate and kind of feeling of agitation
in my body as inappropriate for the moment, right?
And my goal then as an organism is to adjust
my level of what they call autonomic arousal
or alertness down.
If I'm in a great party or I'm at a wedding
or it's a celebration or I'm at a protest or, you know,
then I might feel that my level of alertness
is appropriate for my environment.
So the nervous system is in this constant,
dynamic interaction with the outside world
and trying to figure that out.
One way and this can be kind of conceptualized
is there's an emerging idea that's kind of interesting
about impatience.
So we've all had the feeling of being impatient.
Some people are far more patient than others,
but if you've ever been in line at the store
and you feel like something's going very slowly, you know,
the person in front of you is taking a long time,
they're doing some returns, you're getting kind
of impatient, maybe you're breathing in a mask,
and you're like, ah, like you're, you know,
what's the ideas that if you're getting a certain frequency
of pulses from your body,
and if those pulses are coming in quickly,
like you're perceiving yourself that interoception quickly,
it's like pulse, pulse, pulse, pulse.
You're gonna be more geared
towards your internal representation.
And then you're seeing what's going on in the outside world.
And it seems like it's going very slowly,
but there are other times when you're in line at the store,
someone's getting some returns and you're texting
on your phone or you've had a great day,
you've had a great run, your family's in great shape,
and you're fine, why?
Well, that frequency of those pulses, that interoception,
is matched pretty well to your outside environment.
And so impatience is really when your internal
sort of metronome, tick, tick, tick, tick,
is not matched well to the external environment.
There are other times when you're feeling
like your internal metronome is tick, tick, tick,
and you've got a million things coming at you through email
or texts, you've got a bunch of things and you're feeling
overwhelmed and tired.
Well, in either case there's nothing right or wrong
it's just your body and your brain are trying to say
what's going on in the outside world,
and how well matched am I to it?
Right.
So if you think about some of the, sort of core practices
of mindfulness and self-regulation of like focusing
on breathing or focusing on, you know, state of mind,
a lot of that is trying to bring more awareness
to your internal state,
but what our brain is normally doing when our eyes are open
and we're interacting in the world
is we're constantly trying to update our internal state
to match external demands of the world.
And this hearkens back to a, you know,
like a really early design of all nervous systems
which is how do you take an organism that needs
certain things, food, water, mates, reproduction, shelter.
How do you move that organism?
How do you create a system that will do that
in best relation to the environment?
And so what mother nature has done is designed a system
a series of systems.
Let's just take agitation and stress for one,
if an animal or a human is very thirsty
you feel kind of agitated might get up
and get a drink of water.
If you're very thirsty,
it can put you into a state of panic.
If you're extremely thirsty and water is a limited resource
you might even result the violence to get it
or negotiation of some sort that you wouldn't
if you were calmer.
So the stress and agitation were designed
to actually mobilize the body
to take us into the direction of something that's adaptive.
So you can start to see these kind of core elements
of what the brain and nervous system do.
Sensation, perception, feeling, thought, and action
and this constant challenge
of trying to match our internal state
to the external real estate, the outside world.
And you start to see that the sensations that we call stress
or impatience or calm are really the result
of those attempts that the nervous system
is trying to perform.
That's a lot to take in and super interesting.
And it, you know, it's prompting in me this,
you know, attempt to try to wrap my head around
what within the brain is mutable, which is kind of, you know
what your work is all about versus what is immutable
like you were talking about thoughts
like pop up windows on a browser.
You know, some, sometimes our brains are just doing
what they do and that there are things that we can do
like mindfulness and breath work
and the practices that you're talking about,
hypnosis which is another thing that you're involved in
to help, you know, help us like take better,
manage better that process to kind of take the reins
and be more in charge rather than be prey or victim
to these kinds of things that just occur
without our conscious awareness.
Well, I think that, you know,
in terms of value of understanding the nervous system
and where it can be steered,
it's absolutely clear that the nervous system can change
in response to experience.
So this thing we call neuroplasticity is really that,
it's the brain's ability to modify itself
in response to experience.
And I think it's important to understand that from birth
till about age 25, the brain is extremely malleable,
in a kind of almost passive way where kids are exposed
to things and the brain is just wiring up.
I mean, the brain is designed to adjust itself,
in order to be in concert with its surroundings
and to optimize that just the way we described it
a minute ago.
Like a way that a child can learn a language
very quickly-
Or three languages.
Play a guitar or something like that.
Yeah, without an accent, you know,
three languages without an accent, it's remarkable
and try and do that after age 25, it's very challenging.
And so the brain is basically designed to be customized
in the early part of life,
and then to implement those algorithms
in that circuitry for the rest of your, of its life.
And so the brain can change in adulthood
and it can change provided that there's an emphasis
on some perceptual event.
So in other words, if you wanna change your brain
as an adult, let's say you wanna be less anxious,
you wanna learn a new language,
you wanna be more functional in some way, presumably,
the key thing is to bring focus
to some particular perception
of something that's happening during the learning process.
And the reason for that is that
there's a neurochemical system involving acetylcholine.
And it comes from these two little nuclei
down in the base of the brain called the nucleus basalis.
All day long you're doing things in a reflexive way,
but when you do something and you think about it
very intensely, acetylcholine is released from basalis
at the precise neurons that were involved in that behavior
and it marks those for change
during sleep or during deep rest later.
So for people that wanna change their brain,
the power of focus is really the entry point
and the ability to access deep rest and sleep.
Because most people don't realize this
but neuroplasticity is triggered by intense focus,
but neuroplasticity occurs during deep sleep and rest.
And we can talk about how to optimize
those different brain functions.
One of the things that's really important
also to think about how the brain works
in terms of plasticity and all this stuff
is what the brain really wants to do is also pass as much
of what it does off to reflexive behavior as possible.
So, when we're talking about focus
I think it can get a little bit vague,
but it might be useful to think about like
what exactly is focus and what triggers plasticity?
So the brain loves to be able to just do things,
pick up coffee cups and drink and walk
and talk and do things and not put much energy into it.
When we decide to focus what the brain really does
is it switches on a set of circuits
then all the frontal cortex
and nucleus basalis and some others
and it's trying to understand duration,
how long something's gonna last, path, what's gonna happen,
and outcome, what ultimately is gonna happen.
So duration, path and outcome.
You know, the events of early 2020
are a good example of this.
One of the reasons why it's so exhausting to be alive
in 2020, is because we are now having to pay attention
to duration, path and outcome.
How long is this thing gonna last?
When are, you know, when are they gonna open up
all businesses?
Did I touch that door handle?
Does it matter?
You know, who are the experts?
Are there any experts?
You know, there are a lot of questions
whereas normally, we can just move through life
without having to do all that analysis.
So if it's a simple example
like trying to learn a new language or a new motor skill,
or a new way of conceptualizing something,
maybe somebody who's in a therapeutic process
and they're trying to work through a trauma
or something like that,
duration, path and outcome is built
into the networks of the brain.
We can do that very easily, but it takes work.
And it almost has a feeling
of underlying agitation and frustration.
And that's because of the circuits that turn on
before acetylcholine are of the stress system.
So when you or I decide we're gonna learn something
and really dig in, norepinephrine which is adrenaline
is secreted in the brainstem and in the body.
And it brings about a state of alertness.
Then our attention which is mostly a diffuse light
is brought to a particular duration,
path and outcome analysis.
This would be thinking about what somebody is saying,
what are they really trying to say?
A hard passage of reading, a hard, you know,
set of math problems, you know,
a challenging physical workout.
When you do that, these two systems have to work very hard
and the adult brain doesn't really wanna change
the algorithms they learned in childhood.
But if you do those two things,
you have alertness and focus, the acetylcholine
and the norepinephrine converge
to mark those synopsis for change.
And so, so the way to think about neuroplasticity
if one wants to change their brain is bring
about the most intense concentration you can to something.
And then later bring
about the least amount of concentration to that thing.
So I'll talk about that in a second,
but there were some studies that were done at Stanford
by a guy named Eric Knudsen that showed that plasticity
in the adult brain any age, can be as robust
as it is in childhood, as fast and as dramatic,
provided the focus is there and it's all contingent
on this acetylcholine molecule coming from nucleus basalis.
So you say, well, how do you do that?
How do you get it, you know?
Well, I've got friends that you nicorette thinking
that's gonna get them there
because nicorette is a nicotinic acetylcholine agonist
but that's gonna globally increase acetylcholine.
So I always tell them that's not the right approach.
The right approach is to bring as much focus
to a behavior or to a thought or to an action pattern
and there has to be a sense of urgency.
So what Knudsen lab showed and another lab at UCF
Mike Merzenich's lab showed is that
if there's a serious contingency, like in order
to get your ration of food each day,
you have to learn this thing.
The degree of plasticity is remarkable.
But if there isn't an incentive,
it just isn't gonna happen.
So the circuits in the brain that mother nature set up,
are designed to be anchored to a real need.
And people always say to me, well, should I do something
out of love and a real desire to learn,
or should it be out of fear, but either one works.
The sense of urgency is just acetylcholine.
It's norepinephrine, that's all it is.
It doesn't, the brain doesn't have a recognition
of whether or not something is pleasureful or not
until later.
Once you start accomplishing your goal,
the reward systems like dopamine start kicking in.
But I think if people are interested
in modifying their brain for the better, at least some,
you know, top contour understanding of how urgency
and focus must converge for that to happen can be useful.
Because I think there's a lot of attention paid
to whether or not something feels like flow
or whether or not it's see what I call
highly desirable states or whether or not you can,
you can eat a plant out of the ground
that will magically put your brain
into a state of plasticity.
And the answer is yes, such plants exist,
but what's missing is the focus component.
If that work is not done with a particular end goal in mind,
you'll get plasticity, but you'll get plasticity
in a kind of across the board,
it's like learning nine lang, learning a little bit
of nine languages all at once, is not gonna make you
speak coherently in any one of them.
So focus is the key.
Right, I mean, this idea of flow
is so much in the vernacular now.
And you know, my sense is that people
are trying to measure their level of engagement
against some sort of theoretical idea
of what it's like to be in that flow state.
And if they're not experiencing it,
they feel like they're doing it wrong
or they're, they feel guilty or they beat themselves up.
And for me, it's, a lot of it is just hard work.
Like right now, I'm trying to finish this book
and I should have been working
on this book for like the last nine months, right?
And I just couldn't, couldn't get it together.
Like it's a collaborative project.
So there's a lot of different people
that are involved in this,
and they've been working diligently sort of daily, you know
putting this thing together.
And I've just been focusing on the podcast
and been unable to immerse myself in this project
because I know from past book projects, when I go in,
I go all in, like the addict in me kicks in
and it's like, it just becomes my universe.
And I've been completely paralyzed from taking that on.
And so I've dithered away most of the quarantine
without being productive on this project.
And then about 10 days ago, we had a meeting,
and we established this deadline at, you know,
July 10th to turn this thing in.
And it was like a switch got flicked.
And I went all in and it's all I can think about now.
And in fact, everything else feels like extraneous
and a distraction.
I just wanna get back so I can focus on this thing.
And 10 days ago, I couldn't get myself into that position.
And it's made me think about like,
what is going on in my brain that, you know,
it's such a drastic state change.
And what did I do to switch that
while a deadline was imposed upon me and whatever happened
neuro-chemically with that set in motion
like a chain reaction of events that got me into the chair.
And once I began the project for me,
it's all about like momentum, right?
It's like, to start getting to the starting line
and beginning is so hard.
Like, I will just go forever without doing it.
And then I'm in, and then I'm all in 110%.
And I'm like, why can't I just,
why can't I be that person who just worked on it, you know
an hour and a half every day for the last three months?
Well, I can offer some potential explanations.
I can relate.
And none of it involves a flow state.
It's all hard.
Yeah, and you know, I'm friends with Steven Kotler
I think flow and I think the chicks in Mohali
who originated this thing of flow is really interesting.
But I say right now, the most we can say about flow
mechanistically is backwards it spells wolf.
We don't really understand flow.
Now people have come up with these theories.
It's like, you know, hypo hyper frontality.
I haven't seen the data and I'm not picking on anybody.
I'm putting that out there
as a prompt for people to discover this.
I think that, and to work on it.
I think it's a really interesting, highly desirable state
but I think we need to get comfortable as a culture
in trying to understand our species and how we work,
that the early stages of hard work
and focus are gonna feel like agitation,
stress and confusion, because that's the norepinephrine
and adrenaline system kicking in.
None of us would expect to walk into the gym
and do our PR lift, or, you know,
a performer go do something without warming up.
The brain also needs to warm up
and start to hone in which circuits are gonna be active.
And it's unreasonable for us to think,
"Oh I've got an hour, I'm gonna plop down
and write beautifully for an hour my best work."
We need to accept that there's a period
of agitation and stress that accompanies the dropping
into these highly concentrated states.
Now, in terms of the reward that accompanies the feeling
that we're funneling into that groove
of being productive in one regime
like for you writing this book,
the dopamine system is really important to understand.
So we've talked about norepinephrine kind of
gets you going, acetylcholine is the spotlight of attention.
The dopamine system is mother nature's hardwired,
ancient system in all animals
including humans to put us on the right path.
Now it's, a lot of people talk about dopamine
as this thing that you get when you publish the book
or when you get the book deal
or when something wonderful happens like your child's born.
And that's true, but dopamine's main role is to be released
anytime you achieve a milestone,
or you think you're on the right path.
And when the dopamine system is tethered
to a particular pattern of focus,
remember duration, path and outcome.
So it's like, okay, you sit down,
maybe you don't get much text out
but then the next day you get 800 words
of really solid text and you feel good, like I'm into this.
What does that dopamine system do?
The dopamine system takes the norepinephrine
which is normally rate limiting.
Like at some point there's so much norepinephrine
that you quit and we can talk about that.
It's actually the substrate for quitting,
dopamine can push that noradrenaline back down,
that adrenaline back down and give you more room,
more space to do duration, path and outcome work,
highly focused work.
And I'm making duration path outcomes
synonymous with highly focused work.
Why would this happen?
So let's think about an animal.
Let's think about a deer that wakes up and is thirsty
and it's wandering out looking for water.
That animal needs water.
It doesn't know that it needs water.
It experiences agitation the same way that a baby
feels agitation when it wants food
but it doesn't know it needs food.
It just feels agitation and cries
and a caretaker comes, hopefully.
That deer is now foraging for something that it needs.
And let's say it smells water,
'cause a deer can actually do that and arrives at a stream
and takes a sip of water, there's dopamine released then,
that puts it on a path to maybe a larger lake
or something of that sort, or to be able to go cheap food.
So when we are on the right path,
and we hit a milestone, dopamine is released
and it tends to tighten our focus more for that activity.
So the dopamine, this is why drugs of abuse
and why alcoholism and some process addictions,
which are behavioral addictions are so dangerous
because they, a lot of those drugs of abuse are dopamine.
So it becomes this cyclical loop where there's
no other behavior that can evoke the same level of release.
In fact, I sort of define addiction
as a progressive narrowing of the things
that bring you pleasure.
And I say that
because it really is the way that the dopamine system works.
Normally the dopamine system is designed to be generic.
It's designed to get me to do lots of things,
social quality, social interactions
you know, work, exercise, all those things,
just like the stress system is designed to get me
out of bed in the morning,
cortisol pulse is what gets me out of bed in the morning.
It's also what leads me to, or led me to pursue a career
in science out of fear, initially, and eventually pleasure.
So the dopamine system is tethered to those states of focus
and it's what mother nature designed
so that the neuroplasticity would occur
and you would want to continue those behaviors again
in the future.
That deer needs to know and remember
and create a memory, not just aware that stream is,
but the process of, oh, when I feel that agitation
I'm gonna get up and go down this particular path.
And so people think of the dopamine system
as this kind of like catch all for reward,
oh, you get likes on Instagram and it makes you feel good.
That's not really how it works.
And the important thing to understand
is when you start getting a convergence of norepinephrine
so that level of agitation
duration, path, outcome, acetylcholine, and dopamine,
now you're starting to wire in the behaviors
that make people really good at certain things.
Now in a functional view of this, so not addiction,
what this means is that for any of us,
success in any endeavor is very closely related
to how much focus we can bring to that endeavor.
And the reward system you start to realize
is entirely internal, no one's coming along
and cramming dopamine in your ear
or dripping it in your brain, it's all internal.
And this starts to bring us
into the kind of like discussion around mindsets.
Because, so my colleague Carol Dweck,
who popularized this thing, growth mindset,
it's and again, a very misunderstood concept.
It's the idea that we can change.
So that's built into that, but the discovery
of growth mindset was of these kids that actually
really enjoyed doing problem sets
that they knew they couldn't get, right?
But for them, they would get this like dopamine release
from just focusing on the problem.
They liked doing puzzles they couldn't get right.
It sounds crazy, but inevitably,
those kids are very good at puzzles
and very good at math and on these kinds of things.
So growth mindset is I believe,
if a certain neuroscience lens on growth mindset
would be that the agitation and stress that you feel
at the beginning of something
and when you're trying to lean into it
and you can't focus is just a recognized gate.
You have to pass that through that gate
to get to the focus component.
And then if you can reward the effort process
you really start to feel joy
and low levels of excitement in the effort process.
That's that buffering of adrenaline.
That's that feeling like, yes,
I've got a lot of adrenaline in my system
but I'm on the right path.
It feels good to walk up this hill, so to speak.
And when you start to bring those neural circuits together
you really start to create a whole set of circuits
that are designed to be exported to any behavior you want.
So if it's writing a book, great, if it's podcasting great,
if it's building a business great.
If it's, you know, building a terrific relationship, great
then the circuits that mother nature is designer
incredibly generic so that we could adapt
to whatever it is that we need to do.
And I think the misunderstanding
around how these circuits work,
has led to this idea that there's some secret entry point
maybe marked flow on the door
and there's a trampoline up to that door
and you just open that door and you're gonna be in it.
And nothing could be further from the truth.
And anyone who's done well in any career or athletic pursuit
knows this, but unfortunately there's a kind of obsession
with the idea that it's all supposed to feel good
and it does feel good but there's a whole staircase
in which it feels kind of lousy.
Yeah, I mean, the feel good aspect
of that experience is very subtle.
And I think, you know, in a kind of global way,
what you're talking about is falling in love
with the process.
Like you have to push this gate open, which might require
you know, more effort than you're comfortable with.
But once you push through, it is about, you know, that daily
the daily rigor and the tiny wins that you get from that,
rather than, you know, it's easy to, you know,
you set a goal, but that goal becomes very abstract, right?
And it's those tiny little things that you're getting done
every day that bring you that internal satisfaction
that are like calibrating that plasticity.
Is that what you're saying?
Yeah, absolutely.
And what's incredible is the extent to which the mind
and thoughts, remember earlier we were talking about
how thoughts are spontaneous.
You can't control them,
negative thoughts, traumatic thoughts, bad thoughts,
trying to suppress those is futile.
If there's one message I can send people
it's just don't even work at that,
but work at the process of introducing thoughts
as almost like you would introduce actions,
because we can introduce thoughts.
And, you know, Carol Dweck has talked about this,
that positive self-talk is not the same thing
as growth mindset, because positive self-talk
is almost always linked to the ultimate outcome.
If I'm losing badly in something,
and I tell myself, I'm doing great,
I know that I'm lying.
There's no dopamine release from that.
And you know, a lot of the self-help wellness culture
of the 80s and 90s was like, it's impossible
to be in a bad mood if you're smiling.
We won't have any depression on the planet if that's true.
There's probably some feedback
from the face to the brain, but it's not that simple.
But the idea that you can self reward
the effort process is extremely powerful,
because what it means is
that if you can recognize agitation, stress, and confusion
as an entry point to where you eventually wanna go,
I do think that just that even just mental recognition
can allow people to pass through it more easily.
They think they're doing something wrong
and then rewarding yourself when you achieve any milestone,
like, you know, running to a particular location
if you're trying to run a long distance
and then registering that as a partial win,
what we know is that the dopamine that's released
in response to that suppresses the total amount
of adrenaline and gives you more room, more time,
more energy to run in the running example.
And this is anchored in a real scientific result.
So last year there was a paper published
that essentially was asking why any human
or animal quits at any behavior.
Now, certain behaviors like I can't lift a car,
unless it's a very small car.
I can't lift a car, but if we're talking about running
or we're talking about long bouts of work, the question is,
why do we quit?
Like, what is that?
And it turns out that every time we exert effort,
a certain amount of noradrenaline in the brain is released,
and there's a sort of a counter in the brainstem.
And at some point enough noradrenaline is released
and it shuts down cognitive control, deliberate control
over the motor circuitry, and we quit, that's it.
But the thing that can restore those levels
or it can sort of reset those levels lower
and give us more gas, more mileage, is dopamine.
And it makes perfect sense because our species had to move
against very challenging things in nature
and in certain, so in culture at every stage
of our evolution including now,
2020 is a good example of this.
And when a good example would be,
if you're really slogging it out and things are miserable,
just think like the worst family vacation,
everything's a disaster or a very hard physical event,
and someone cracks a joke,
you're almost immediately feel a sense of relief.
You see this in the team that wins the Super Bowl.
Both teams slogged it out.
You have to believe they were both at max effort
the entire game.
Look at the team that wins,
they have extra energy,
they're jumping all over the place.
So it can't be physical energy.
It can't be glycogen related.
It's not ketone related.
It's nothing in the body in that sense.
It's dopamine's ability to take that level
of norepinephrine and smack it back down.
And so we can learn this, right?
I mean, I think this is where there's real power
like in your story,
or the story that I'm familiar with from your book.
Like the ability to push through those pain points
is something that we really can export
to other aspects of life
because it's the same neuro-chemicals that are involved.
So when you get to a particular location
or maybe your, recall, you know, a portion where you're just
you're feeling lousy, you know, you're injured,
or you feel like you're hurt and you can reframe it mentally
and think I'm actually still on the ladder.
I'm still holding onto a wrong.
I know that at least that much, I'm still breathing.
I know that much.
And the lift that we get is not some psychological pump-up,
it's a neurochemical thing.
It's dopamine suppressing norepinephrine, and saying
you're on the right path, you can keep going.
It's a permission to keep going.
And we grant that permission to ourselves,
no one grants that permission to us.
I think one of the other kind of misconceptions
that we wanna dissolve is this idea
that external rewards can actually propel us
down long paths of success and high performance.
They can't.
It's internal rewards.
No, that's a sustainable
fuel source.
Yeah.
I have a friend from the SEAL team
and somebody asked us recently, we were giving a talk
and somebody said,
"How can I make sure that I continue to self reward,
and I'm not driven by these extra rewards?
How can I continue to have that drive?"
And his answer was very good.
He said, "Give away all the external rewards."
You know, now not everyone can afford to do that.
It's just about you and you.
It's just you and you.
And the more attach there's a famous Stanford study done
at being nursery school, probably not far where
from where you were in the dormitory,
there was a little nursery school in Escondido village.
And they did a study where they looked at kids
that like to playing during their recess,
it's all recess in nursery school, but they're drawing.
And they took the kids that really liked to draw.
And they started giving them little gold stars
on their drawings.
And then they liked the gold stars
for a kid that's an extrinsic reward.
And then they stopped doing that and the kids stop drawing.
They just, they associated the good feeling of doing it
with the external rewards.
We have to be very cautious about how much
of our internal dopamine we attach to external rewards,
if we wanna continue to grow
and pursue and focus and work hard.
If you just wanna get to someplace and cash in, then fine.
But most people find themselves in a pretty miserable place
because their dopamine was so attached to external rewards,
they need more and more of that.
Well, the why has to be deeper than that.
I mean, the thing that I kind of always default to
when I hit that breaking point or, you know
I'm training or I'm racing or whatever,
and I'm at that stage where it's just like,
I can't go any further,
the first thing I do is I reflect inward
on why I'm doing this to begin with, like, what is the,
you know what is the value system
that I'm trying to tap into?
What is it that I'm trying to express?
Like what got me to this point?
So it's a reminder, and then I just set,
like I just say, well, I'm just gonna get
to the next lamppost or I'm gonna, you know,
get to the next intersection or whatever it is.
I break it down into the tiny, I'll quit after that.
Like the more I can just root myself in the present moment
and distill it down into the tiniest of digestible chunks,
that's the only way I can, you know,
continue to move forward.
And I've learned over time that the more I do that, then
you know, suddenly I'll find myself
in a different mental, like it will shift, right?
Just because I feel that way in that moment
is not determinative
of how I'm gonna feel 10 minutes later.
Absolutely, there's an interesting process that occurs
when people start to realize that rewards are all internal
and what they start to do is they start linking
this duration, path, outcome thing,
to their internal rewards.
And so to put this simply one of the most powerful things
that any person can do is to learn to control
this idea of duration, path, and outcome
and attach an internal sense of reward
just that you're doing well to reward yourself mentally
just say, "I'm doing well, I'm actually on the right path."
To do that inside of the demands
that come from the external world.
The more often that we can self reward
some aspect of the process provided
it's in the right direction of what we're trying to achieve,
the more energy we're gonna have for that,
the more focus we're gonna have for that.
And remember that the reason I say energy,
I don't throw that around loosely is that limiting amount
of noradrenaline is constantly being kept at bay.
You literally keep buffering the quit response.
And so when people start realizing
that if they set the goals inside of the larger goal
and self reward each one of those
they essentially have an infinite amount of energy
to pursue those goals.
They have an infinite amount of focus to pursue those goals.
You see this most in the special operations community
and people that are selected essentially for this process.
It's one of the things that's been intriguing to me.
I have some friends from the SEAL teams
and I don't begin to really understand the real work
that they do deployed
'cause I've never done that kind of work
but I've always been intrigued
by the selection process,
the so-called BUD/S process, right?
Because carrying logs and getting in cold water
and all that, that's not really how the work is.
That's really not what the work is about.
So the selection process is interesting
because everyone shows up fit, motivated,
and convinced that they're not gonna quit.
I mean, I think like there might be a couple of days
you'll just show up to show up,
but everybody is absolutely convinced.
And then a very small subset of them make it through.
And I'd be willing to bet
that the ones that make it through,
of course they're gritty and resilient
but they all are essentially, right?
So that's necessary, but not sufficient, obviously,
otherwise they, everyone would make it through.
The people that make it through somehow
are able to tap into a process.
Maybe it's a reward process.
Maybe it's through self punishment,
maybe it's through self reward in the positive sense,
but they're able to control something
inside an environment that is not controlled by them.
It's controlled by the instructors.
And I've always been struck by the fact that in order to
to not in order to get through, you just have to not quit.
Remember people aren't being deselected.
They're not saying, get out of here,
you're not good enough, you're not,
people are deciding that for themselves.
And so it's interesting because it brings
about a real-world experiment of people who are quitting.
And I believe they're quitting because they can't manage
these neurotransmitters.
And the people, when I say manage,
I think that the people that get through
knowing some of these people quite well,
had an internal process
by which they could reward themselves
for doing something that might've just look trivial
to everybody else, but it gave them more gas, more energy.
And what's interesting is the process,
the kind of unconscious genius of the BUD/S process
is that they've picked two sensory events
that are across the board, challenging for everybody.
One is cold water, which is great, because it
most of the time it can't kill you, right?
It's not like heat, which can kill you.
It's cold water and sleep deprivation.
And so the ability to do these, like what I'm calling DPOs
this duration, path and outcome steps and procedures
is great on when you're rested, you know,
you know, when you have, when you're well fed, well slept,
you can do anything.
You can be in any hard conversation
you can work through anything.
So what they do is they start taking
the autonomic nervous system, which is these deep reserves
of the nervous system
that when our autonomic nervous system is off,
it starts making us pay more attention
to how we feel than the demands of the world around us.
Remember that basic challenge in the nervous system.
And so sleep deprivation is the best way
that you can pull somebody down from their ability
to analyze duration, path and outcome and reward themselves.
Sleep deprivation is the way
in which you essentially pull apart the nervous system
and the way that it wants to function
because it's very easy, again, rested to do all this.
But so what they do is they're sleep deprived people
they put them in cold water,
they're trying to get them more in touch
with the way that they feel inside than what they need to do
in response to the external demands.
Everyone I know that's made it through that process,
did it slightly differently
but I'll tell you how they didn't do it.
They didn't do it through sheer grit and determination.
They did it through attaching a sense of meaning.
They did it by micro slicing the day, or slicing the day
into a series of meals that they just needed to get to
and then rewarding themselves
for getting to that next milestone.
So they don't know, I mean, most of them,
you know, probably had very low concept
of dopamine and norepinephrine, but that's the process.
That's also the process
I think that allows someone to finish an ultra.
I've never run an ultra, but I think that process
of self reward is grit and resilience,
in a kind of neurochemical definition.
And I think it's the thing that anybody can tap into.
And I think it's, therefore, I think it's so key
because I think people think that it's just so key
that people understand, excuse me,
that these circuits are not unique
to people who run ultras or people that make it through
you know, stringent filter, special operations command.
These, it's the same thing
that anyone can do.
It is interesting.
Yeah, the ultimate determinant
isn't your physical conditioning.
And yet that's what everybody focuses on.
It's what's going on in, you know,
internally, mentally, neuro-chemically
that's making the difference
and the people that are able to best calibrate that
and find these, you know, strategies for managing
are the ones that get through whether it is an ultra
or BUD/S and BUD/S is like this perfect,
it's almost like its own lab, right?
For studying human resilience in a certain respect
but you have actually taken some of these people
and tested them in your lab, including David Goggins, right?
So, what do you do when you, when these people visit you
and you're like, I'm gonna deconstruct you here,
figure out what makes you tick.
Yeah, so I had the good fortune of meeting David
at a consulting event a few years ago.
And I guess I should just say, David,
you probably know this already, but he is,
every bit is intense as he comes across.
Yeah, I mean,
what you see online.
His private persona is-
Yeah it's exactly the same.
What you see is what you get.
Really wonderful and obviously extremely impressive
human being.
David anecdote, so the night before we had this event,
he came out to the lab.
My lab, we do, we study fear.
We study courage, we say resilience.
And we say the underlying neurochemical substrates
for those.
So we had a bunch of guys there,
a couple of team guys, some other folks, and we bring them
in this little room and we do virtual reality there.
And one of the things that we used to scare people
or to generate a sense of autonomic arousal
is this experience of diving with great white sharks.
Which of course, you're not in water,
you're in the laboratory, but it's very immersive.
And for people that are afraid of sharks,
it can be quite scary, not always,
but we also have heights, we have claustrophobia,
we got something where you can feel spiders
crawling all over your body, if you're an arachnophobe.
You know, if you have a pain point, we find it.
Do you spend time trying to figure out
what that pain point is?
We do and we do it through some very covert methodology
that involves AI and some fun tools.
A bunch of weird questions that, right, all right.
Let's just say this, from the moment you step
into our laboratory, we're studying you.
so the-
Now I know.
And yeah, exactly.
So what was fun was, you know,
so I sort of explained what the platform was
and what we were gonna do.
And David said, he goes, "I don't like sharks."
And I was like, all right, well, and so then, you know,
this was not a typical experimental day in the lab.
So I just kind of, at one point I finished describing
what the tech is and how we're going to wire people in.
And then I said, "So who wants to go first?"
And he's like, I'll go.
Right, of course.
And what was funny to me at that moment
I realized this is interesting because he,
he was very explicit about the fact he didn't like sharks.
He was very explicit about the fact
that he was going to be first, you know, first man in.
I mean, it would be inappropriate
for me to describe his data, right?
And we didn't do a full-blown experiment
but what I can say is he's, whatever it is
that David has figured out how to do,
it clearly involves taking whatever adrenaline pulse
he feels and understanding something fundamental to biology
which is that adrenaline response was designed
to move us not to keep us stationary.
He uses behavior as the way to shift sensation,
perception, feelings, and thoughts.
He understands how to run that program
in the right direction.
Whereas most people, when they don't like what they feel,
they start negotiating sensation, which will never work.
They start trying to control their perception
which is hard, right?
They're like, I'm not gonna think about that
or I'll think about it differently.
Very hard to control the mind with the mind.
He knows that's a tough one.
Yeah.
Feelings, Lord knows what those are
and how to control them.
I mean, we'll eventually figure that out as a field,
but thoughts are complicated.
So he just goes immediately into action.
He goes forward towards it.
So when he says, just for clarity, when he says,
"I don't like sharks", he's basically saying
put me in the shark tank, like, he's cuing you to say
this is the thing I'm afraid of
and I'm gonna be the first one to volunteer
and I know you're gonna put me in the shark tank
if I tell you that, right?
Exactly, and I think, and I obviously can't speak for him,
but one of the things I think is very clear
is that he's tapped into this neuroplasticity process
through the door through the portal of agitation and stress,
he's figured out the, and this is really the holy grail
of neuroscience is how can I modify my brain?
Well, you modify it by placing yourself into discomfort
and using that as a propeller to move you into action.
And, you know, a couple of years later
when David was working on his book
and I heard the book was coming out,
I think I saw a pre-release announcement,
I texted him and I just said, look
"I'm really excited to see your book."
And he said, "Oh great, thank you.
You know, be great if you'd write something
like an endorsement."
I said, "Oh, I'd be honored to, I'm happy to."
And he said, "But I need it tonight."
And this was Saturday.
I think it was like 10:30 at night when I texted him.
So it's a great, well, I'd be happy to, I won't do it now.
He said, "I need it by midnight."
So I sit down and I start writing this thing
and these are short blurbs, but I kind of realized
that you know, you wanna get it right.
It's David and you know, my name's next to it.
And I wanna do do it justice.
So I'm sitting down, I'm working on the saying
and I texted him, "Look, I'm gonna be a few minutes late.
No problem, no problem."
Finally, I sent him the thing at like 12:30 at night
and he's like, "Aw, bro, thank you, thank you, thank you.
I promise I'll send you a copy of this and that."
And I was like, grateful, you know, thank you.
And then I realized that that time he was living in New York
and I said, "Wait a second, where are you?"
He said, "New York."
And I said, "It's 3:30 in the morning."
And he goes, "Yeah, I'm going running."
And I realized at that point, I was like, okay
you know, there's, it's undisputable.
You know this guy lives the persona
that he projects into the world.
And even that day, that consulting gig, you know,
there was a four o'clock lag
and he was like, no, let's keep going.
So he's figured something out.
And I think that his enormous popularity is it's earned,
because he's figured out that it really doesn't matter
if you come at something from a place of joy and love.
And that would be wonderful, but there's a whole other set
of ways to approach this, that involve slogging
through the discomfort, the doubts, the wish for things
to be different and starting with behavior.
And it's incredible 'cause if you think about sensation
perception, feeling, thought and behavior,
actually the way to control our nervous system
and feel the way we wanna feel is to run that backwards.
Behavior, thoughts.
So if you change your behavior, then generally
your thoughts, your feelings and your perceptions change.
And everyone tries to come at it from the other end,
but he's figured out through whatever process led him there
and incredible life circumstances, how to run it
in this direction of behavior first.
And I really think that if neuroscience has anything
to offer, it's some understanding of what the underlying
chemicals and neuro-circuits are, but the sooner
that the human animal, the human species can start
to understand that our feelings and our thoughts
and our memories and our all that is very complicated,
but that when behaviors are very concrete
and they are the control panel for the rest of it.
I don't wanna relegate feelings,
feelings are extremely important.
I don't wanna relegate perception,
they're extremely important, but when it comes to wanting
to shift the way that you function, to get better
or to perform better, or to show up better,
or to move away from things like addictive behaviors,
it's absolutely foolish for any of us, me included,
to think that we can do that by changing our thoughts first,
it's behavior first, thoughts, feelings
and perceptions follow.
Mood follows action.
This is like been my mantra forever.
And, you know, I swear by it.
And David's example illustrates that that act first
he's developed so much neuroplasticity that it's reflexive
for him to just move towards the hard thing
or the challenge or the discomfort, right?
And now the science establishes
that this is indeed the case.
And yet our programming, our default hard wiring is to,
you know, put us in this place where we want to ruminate
on all this stuff.
And wait until we feel like doing something before we do it
or check our motivations for it.
But anytime I'm in a funk or I wanna change my state,
I have to move forward.
I have to do something with my physical body in order
to shake things up and, you know,
rearrange whatever's going on mentally.
So, and it, and it works every time.
It works every time because the brain circuits
meaning sets of connections and chemicals
they're there from birth, they're there your whole life,
and they were designed for that.
So in 2018, a graduate student in my lab published a paper
in Nature, showing that in the face of a physical threat,
there are three options.
You can obviously freeze,
you can retreat, or you can move forward.
And the moving forward response actually triggers activation
of a connection in the brain to the dopamine circuitry
of the brain and makes it more likely
that you're gonna be able to move forward in the future.
Now, what was interesting to us was that,
not only is forward action rewarded at a neurochemical level
which then sets you up for more forward action
but the highest level of agitation and stress was associated
with moving forward, we always think, well,
if I just call myself enough, I'll be able to move forward.
But it's the exact opposite, you know?
And so people who are paralyzed in fear
or that have a hard time initiating, sometimes the key
is to raise the level of stress and agitation.
This is why deadlines are so effective.
This is why fear is so effective.
This is why that deer gets up out of its, you know,
nice little den and starts to move
because it feels a certain level of agitation.
If that agitation isn't high enough,
we will not move forward.
And so, especially in the U.S you know, we have a culture
in which stress has been created, you know, these ideas
around stress is that it's terrible for us.
When in fact stress is designed to move us forward
towards these action steps that are rewarded
which then move us forward and so on.
So what is the process of combating that, you know
monkey mind that is, you know,
running whatever narrative that's keeping you stuck.
Like, it's easy to say, like, just move
you gotta take the action.
But a lot of people still, despite understanding that,
intellectualizing that, are unable to, you know,
basically act as if.
Yeah, I think we're dealing with two general categories
of people who have problems with motivation and focus.
And I think we've failed to decide, excuse me,
I think we failed to describe the fact
that there are two groups and not one we think,
well I need to calm myself enough to move forward.
I think, and then other people say, well, no
you need to kind of ramp yourself up to move forward.
Here's the way I conceptualize it
based on the data that I'm aware of.
Some people are just hypo aroused.
They're just not motivated enough.
And those people would benefit greatly
from cultivating practices, like super oxygenated breathing.
So this is something along the lines
of like tummo type breathing, so rapid.
And we look at this and allow
we're actually running a human study on this now.
So 25 or 30 deep breaths through the nose and out
through the mouth, then exhaling the breath and holding,
learning to how to self generate adrenaline.
That's what you're doing when you're doing that.
Some version of the Wim Hof technique.
That's what that is.
Brian McKenzie talks about.
Right, an ice bath is doing the exact same thing,
stimulating adrenaline response.
It actually improves the immune system.
There's a published paper on this, releases adrenaline
which buffers the immune system against infection
but getting good at taking yourself from low,
low energy to higher energy
and then learning how to compress your focus.
And I'll talk about the focus thing in a minute.
Some people are so agitated, the monkey mind
they got too many things going on and they're thinking, okay
they're trying to sit down and write.
I suffer from this, and I'm feeling like, wait
I've also got this person I need to connect with.
And I'm kind of being drawn off course
by not being able to put the blinders on.
For people that have that issue,
I think learning how to calm the nervous system
is very powerful.
And the best way that I know how to do that is based
on two studies, one published in Nature, one published
in Cell Reports recently showing that physiological size
there's actually a thing in the literature
called physiological size, are one of the fastest ways
to bring our overall level of sub autonomic arousal down.
And a physiological sigh is a two inhales,
followed by an extended exhale.
So it's like, it's not just a deep breath.
It's two inhales followed by an exhale, okay?
And what that, what that does.
And this has been shown several times now in humans
and other species, as well is it dilates
the little sacks of the lungs and that second inhale
dilates them a little bit more,
and it pulls a little bit of carbon dioxide
out of the bloodstream so that when we exhale,
we offload the maximum amount of carbon dioxide
and it perfectly adjust the ratio of carbon dioxide
and oxygen in the bloodstream and lungs.
And sometimes it only takes one of these double
inhale exhale.
Sometimes somebody needs to do two or three,
but that's the fastest way
to bring the autonomic nervous system down.
A lot of people need such a tool because I think
we talk a lot about meditation and tools for calm
and, you know I can go to Esalen for a weekend
and get a massage, I'm gonna feel very good,
but then when I'm thrown back in real life
I need something that's gonna work in real time.
What I call a real time tool.
And most people don't know how to control
their autonomic nervous system because it's complicated.
I can't control my liver function.
I can eat that will calm me,
but that has complicated, you know, issues with it too
if I'm just eating to calm myself.
So the diaphragm is the one skeletal muscle organ
that was internally, right?
We've got obviously skeletal muscles
designed to move things.
It's a skeletal muscle organ, unlike the spleen, the liver,
the heart, et cetera
it was designed to be moved voluntarily.
And these physiological size are actually
occurring fairly regularly during sleep,
to adjust our levels of carbon dioxide and oxygen.
And there's a recent study showing that in claustrophobia
this is the breathing pattern that people default to,
to try and offload that carbon dioxide.
So, whereas there are a lot
of really interesting breathing techniques,
Wim Hof, Brian McKenzie does great work.
Patrick McHugh, you know, the Laird and Gabby, there're tons
of people doing really interesting things out there.
My lab has been focused on what are the neural circuits
that are designed to achieve particular states
that happen to impinge on and capture diaphragm function.
And so the reason I think breathing is so powerful
is that everyone has a diaphragm
and it's the immediate link to the body.
A lot's been made at the vagus nerve.
You know, oh, the vagus is the path
between the body and mind, but the vagus is very slow.
The vagus nerve calming is what you experience
when you eat a really rich carbohydrate-rich meal
or you've had a long day and you put your feet up
and you're finally relaxing.
It takes minutes to hours to kick in.
Whereas the diaphragm is real-time control
over your brain state.
So the brain knows what the body is doing
by how fast the diaphragm is moving.
It knows its overall activation state.
So when you breathe quickly
those 25 or 30 breaths, the brain says, oh, I must be alert.
I'm gonna start secreting some noradrenaline.
And when you breath slowly,
that level of noradrenaline drops down.
So it sounds so simple, but I think it's only in the last
two or three years that my lab and Mark Krasnow's lab
at Stanford and other labs elsewhere in the world
have started to identify the neurons
in the brain that are linked to breathing
and how those two things relate to one another.
And I think everybody should have a kit of tools
that they can use to bring themselves down
and ramp themselves up.
I'll just say one other thing about focus.
So when we're in a high alert state,
something very powerful happens
that I think partially explains your your ability now
to drop into this book writing.
When there's a certain amount of adrenaline in our system,
our pupils dilate,
remember the eyes are not connected to the brain.
Our eyes are actually two pieces of central nervous system.
They are two pieces of brain outside the skull
that were designed to control our overall arousal state.
And so we can talk about this as it relates to sleep
and sleep quality, but when I bring up the level
of adrenaline in my body through breathing, or let's say
I see a troubling text, or let's just say,
I just use a very Goggins-type-approach
and just figure out the most painful, inspiring for me
reason to do it, you know, it sounds vague,
'cause obviously David
I don't know what goes on in your head
but a tremendous respect for your ability to do this.
But he just ratchets himself out of that ditch
and puts himself in motion, the pupils dilate,
and when that happens,
our visual system actually enters something
that's a little bit more like portrait mode on our phone.
There's a process called accommodation
and your ability to focus on one thing visually
actually becomes better
and your ability to see everything else blurs away.
And that's the ability to just see that screen of text
or that if you were work on, you know, pad and paper
to just see that pad and paper.
And then as you start writing, what people don't realize is
that mental focus follows visual focus.
Now in blind people, it's slightly different,
it follows auditory focus, but in most people,
your visual focus as you bring that
into really sharp relief, that image of your book
and you stare at you're gonna feel some agitation
and your mind's gonna be jumping all over the place.
But if you wait just a couple minutes,
the rest of the world will disappear.
I think this is sort of like the flow state
people are looking for.
But remember the gate of entry is one of which
you have to wade through some sewage
before you can swim in clear water.
That's the way I always think about it.
But the visual focus is what brings the rest of the brain
into cognitive focus
and people in the martial arts understand this.
You've probably experienced this running when
you're feeling exhausted and you can just concentrate
on one milestone and get there.
You can almost bring that into like you
what you're doing is you're linking that
to the dopamine circuitry.
You're saying that thing is the milestone
not winning the race, not some other thing outside this,
this immediate environment, that thing.
And when you're able to start capturing
these peripheral circuits, meaning the body, the diaphragm,
the visual system, then you start getting past
this whole idea of mindsets
and it really becomes about the body setting the mind.
And this is where I think when you say action
leads the rest, right?
It's that's what you're saying is grounded
in real neuro biological data.
There's also a shift in your perception of time
when you're in that state, you know,
suddenly your relationship with time
becomes completely different.
So, I'm really glad you-
And I'm not like, you know,
it's easy to say it slows down or it speeds up,
to me it's neither.
You're in this weird liminal state
where it's almost like it doesn't exist.
It's not, it's not a relevant like vector in your,
in your emotional experience.
I'm really glad you brought this up
because one of my obsessions is time perception.
And, you know, having spent the last 20 years
or so studying the visual system
what you start to realize is that space,
meaning physical space, not outer space, but physical space
around you and your time perception are absolutely linked.
And when our focus is very narrow,
time starts to feel thin sliced.
So, you're right.
It's not that it's going fast or slow,
it's that you're perceiving more events per unit time.
So it's like a metronome that's going faster.
When our gaze is dilated,
so when we're relaxed, there's actually a,
what happens is the pupil kind of relaxes a bit.
It doesn't always get bigger or smaller
but what happens is when we're relaxed,
so if you view a horizon for instance,
or you go into what's called panoramic vision,
so even though I'm looking at you right now,
I can dilate my gaze without moving my head or eyes.
So I can see the corners of the room and the ceiling.
I can see myself in the environment, when we do that,
our perception of time broadens.
And we feel like we have more time.
And what we're doing when we do that focus
versus de-focus as I call it,
or focal vision versus panoramic vision is you're toggling
on and off the autonomic nervous system for alertness,
you're turning on and off that norepinephrine circuit.
And so it's conscious control over a brainstem circuit.
And this is why I don't like the phrase autonomic,
'cause that means automatic, it's a misnomer.
All the breathing I can control my autonomic nervous system.
I can breathe, I can control my autonomic nervous system,
I can eat a big meal.
I can control my autonomic nervous system,
I can focus or de-focus.
And if you really look at the realm of high-performance
what you start to realize is people who are very good
at their respective sport or career
or in the special operations community what they do,
are exceptionally good at turning it on and off
these systems.
So they're highly functional at achieving their milestones
but they're not spending out extra energy.
Because when you go into panoramic vision,
you start to uncouple the space time thing
and you get some rest and relaxation.
The way to think about this
as we go back to duration, path and outcome,
that's the most stringent high focus regime for the brain.
The way to get better
at duration, path, and outcome is to engage
in activities that are low duration, path, and outcome
where your brain is not in modes
of analyzing duration, path, and outcome.
What's the one phase of our life when we're not thinking
about duration, path, and outcome at all?
Sleep, and so the reason why
you can pull somebody's mind apart,
their ability to think rationally and analyze duration,
path and outcome by sleep depriving them, is because sleep
despite all its neurochemical complexity is really when
we restore our ability to analyze duration,
path and outcome. Now you think about BUD/S and you go
no wonder they're sleep deprived.
They're trying to figure out who has the ability to control
these mechanisms and who doesn't, most people fail.
So when I think about how to recover,
I've I actually don't think about recovery as its own thing.
I think about recovery as giving buoyancy
or improving my ability to focus.
So sleep is the turning off of these brain circuits
that are thinking about what's happening next.
So some people experience challenges in falling asleep,
they need to learn how to turn off thinking.
And there's actually a way to do this.
We're doing a study on this now, it relates to hypnosis.
That will be fun to talk about.
And we can, if you like, the other thing is that
just merely going into panoramic vision,
say between a meeting instead of looking at your phone,
more focal vision we're hard on your book.
Maybe you walk to the kitchen, just two seconds of,
what I call deliberate decompression, where you just kind of
let your mind go broader, will allow you to reset your focus
much more intensely when you return to that book
as opposed to if you'd looked at your phone
or engaged even in some other kind of deep duration,
path, outcome type function of the brain.
So when you start thinking about meditation,
it's also valuable because a lot of meditation
involves focusing on your breath.
I actually think a lot of people
are spending out this ability.
They're working too hard in the activities
that are designed to reset them.
So the two ways to reset yourself in wakefulness.
Being just very adamant about my meditation practice.
That's right.
Because it's an, it's a letting go.
It's not it's, you know, it's we're so programmed
to like force ourselves to do things
or to like dive in with intentionality.
But so much of this is more elusive than that.
I think that we can all do ourselves a great service
and perform much better in what we're doing
by taking little micro recoveries in the form of dilating
our gaze in between meetings, just for a second,
viewing a horizon is the best way to do it
because it naturally brings the eyes into de-focus.
We're doing this in VR because we can control
the visual environment completely.
When you go into this de-focus mode, you turn off
that brainstem circuit, you're conserving norepinephrine
for your next bout of focus in activity.
Otherwise you're spending it and the brain doesn't care
how you spend it.
Doesn't care if it's on Instagram, doesn't care
if it's watching the news, but learning how to de-focus
and then refocus very quickly can get you through a race
that you wouldn't otherwise have been able to get through.
It saves you energy and it builds energy.
The other thing is we talk a lot about sleep
and sleep is extremely important, but there are other modes
of, and brain states that can allow you to recover.
One of the ones that I'm a huge proponent of
and that my lab has been studying and other labs
are studying is what many people call yoga nidra,
where you-
I've done yoga nidra a lot.
It's a wonderful practice, you know, just lying down
and focusing enough of your attention
so that you don't fall asleep and enough of your attentions
on and moving it around
so that you're not really concentrating on any one thing.
I fall asleep every time.
I do too, yeah, I do too.
But what we know,
so I fundamentally disagree with respectfully though,
with the idea that we can't recover sleep that we've lost.
Because what are we really talking about there?
For me it's the ability to perform these duration,
path, outcome analysis.
So in my lab, we have people do a cognitive task
and then we place them into these very deep states
of relaxation through things
that are kind of like yoga nidra
and people can find yoga nidra scripts out there.
They're everywhere on YouTube, elsewhere,
or we have them do a hypnosis script.
Hypnosis is very similar, deep relaxation,
wandering sort of attention, fairly narrow context,
but it brings the brain into these unique states
where you're neither asleep nor awake.
And for people that have trouble falling asleep,
or trouble relaxing themselves, these kinds of practices
are extremely useful,
because they're really teaching you how to turn off
those modes of focus.
So, you know, we live in a stress society.
Some people are stressed 'cause they're overwhelmed
but other people are stressed because they just don't know
how to turn off their brain and fall asleep.
And so if you wanna learn how to turn off your brain
and fall asleep, these practices are immensely useful.
How do you practice hypnosis by yourself though?
So there's some scripts.
I would recommend people go to one of the scripts
on YouTube or there's some good ones I've never met him.
I don't have any relationship to him, but Michael Sealey,
S-E-A-L-E-Y, an Australian guy
has some really good hypnosis scripts.
And they're just audio programs?
Yeah, you just listen to them and these-
And he's not gonna make you walk off a cliff or anything.
No, so stage hypnosis is very different.
So I have a very close collaboration
with a guy named David Spiegel,
who's in our psychiatry department at Stanford.
We're now looking at how daily breathing exercises
can impact people's sleep and levels of stress.
He's done a lot of work on addiction and trauma
and pain management through hypnosis
and most all of hypnosis that's clinical
involves bringing one's state
into one of deeper relaxation, not full sleep.
And then thinking about some behavioral change
that one wants to make.
These are ancient practices, really.
And I think that they were developed
by people that understood that rewiring
of the brain requires focus and deep rest.
What's interesting about hypnosis is it brings
those two things together at the same moment.
So normally you'll work really hard
on something work really hard, then you'll sleep
and that's when the plasticity occurs.
But hypnosis likely accelerates that whole process
by having people enter a state of deep relaxation
and focus at the same time
and allows those circuits to reshape themselves.
And there's some published data
from David's lab to support that.
That's fascinating.
So I think these practices are really useful.
And I think that if you wanna get better at performing
everyone now knows thanks to Matt Walker's book
and others like "Sleep More, Sleep Better,"
but what if you have trouble sleeping,
well or falling asleep?
Well, we want to define what that is.
Some people have a hard time turning off their thoughts.
It's really hard, remember you can't do it.
What you can do is to learn to control
that perceptual window and distribute it so that your sense
of time starts to kind of drift off
and you end up in sleep more easily.
And it's a practice that most people find if they do it
for 10 minutes a day or so, they start sleeping
much better within a week or more.
And sometimes more, they sometimes people need
some other help, like not drinking caffeine
late in the day et cetera.
But that brain state of no duration,
path and outcome analysis is gonna be the most restorative
and you can get it in wakefulness too.
So taking a walk where you're just letting your mind go
is very powerful.
And the other thing that's powerful is optic flow.
So self-generated optic flow by walking, running,
or cycling shifts the brain into a state of relaxation
that's not seen when you're stationary.
This is well-described in the neuroscience literature
for some reasons not well-described
in the wellness literature, but it's a real thing.
When you move through space, you're active,
you're, there's a natural calming of the brain circuits
involved in threat and threat detection.
This is the basis for EMDR,
eye movement desensitization reprocessing,
the lateralized eye movements they have people do
in the clinic that on a goofy-looking thing
while they do counter trauma.
I've heard you talk
about that, to overcome fear and trauma.
That lowers stress and the rationale is that
by coupling a low stress state, to the recall of the trauma
it's gonna allow people to reshape the relationship
to the trauma, to tolerate that discomfort.
And it, EMDR my clinical colleagues tell me
works best for fairly well-defined traumas.
It's not gonna be like my childhood or, you know
a whole series of events, but for single event traumas
or trauma that's repeated, but of the same sort,
it seems to work best.
It's not gonna work best to completely reshape
all relationships to all traumas,
but it does seem to be powerful
for a certain group of people.
So, basically an example would be if you got
into a car accident, and then you're afraid to get in a car
or something like that, right?
So you take this person and you submit them
to this therapy where they move their eyes
back and forth laterally, which seems absurd.
Seems goofy, right.
So this is supposed to help them
get over their fear or their blockage?
Yeah, so, okay.
So my lab studies vision and we study stress
and states of mind, and people used to talk
to me about EMDR and asked me about EMDR.
And I was like, this is crazy.
This sounds like a music genre.
This is absurd, right?
Or a drug.
Makes no sense, why would moving the eyes
from side to side, have any impact on states of mind?
That's ridiculous.
But then what happened was in 2018, 2019 and 2020,
five quality manuscripts came out in very good journals,
from groups that were studying eye movements,
not studying stress or trauma that found
that these lateralized eye movements not up and down,
but lateralized eye movements,
quiet the activity of the amygdala,
the limbic structure in the brain
that's primarily responsible for threat detection
and stress.
And I was like, oh my goodness
this thing might actually be real.
Then I started to dig into the backstory of this.
And there was a woman named Francine Shapiro
who came up with this idea, actually walking behind Stanford
in the Stanford Hills, she was a therapist.
And she figured she had this idea based on the fact that she
didn't feel as upset about certain things
when she was walking, that this might be useful.
And she was smart enough to know
that these lateralized eye movements
are what reflexively occur anytime we're in optic flow.
We don't realize it 'cause they're subconsciously generated
and they're very subtle,
but she realized she couldn't really take people walking
on their therapy sessions, I suppose she could,
but it's not really practical, it's raining, et cetera.
So what she decided to do
was to bring the eye movement component to the clinic
and have them move their eyes from side to side
while they would recount these traumas,
and people experienced tremendous benefit.
And in fact, now there's a lot of evidence to show
that these lateralized eye movements
really do quiet the stress of the nervous system
and allow people to continue to move forward.
This is probably all anchored.
I go back to that story of that deer that needs something.
And as it's feeling that agitation and gets up
and starts moving, the movement feeds back
onto the brain to quiet that stress and anxiety.
So it can be observant of its environment.
And that panoramic mode is what we are in
when we are in a position to be very situationally aware.
When we're stressed, we are gonna have, you know,
soda straw view of the world, right?
This relates directly to addiction
because I've spent some time at addition treatment clinics
and talking to people in that community.
And it's very clear that of course there are a huge number
of factors that play into why people become addicted
and relapse, et cetera.
But if you can get at people's ability
to control their anxiety,
and their feelings of peak states and happiness,
you don't guarantee, but you help reinforce the possibility
that they're gonna get sober and stay sober.
As an addict gets more tethered
to the idea that some substances, the thing they need,
the progressive narrowing
of the things that bring them pleasure
and everything else kind of falls away
like portrait mode on the phone,
they're essentially in a state of high stress
trying to meet that dopamine need all the time
and they don't see other possibilities.
The reason I mentioned not just stress
and treating stress to get at addiction
but also pleasure is that we've also seen this.
When do people relapse?
When they're feeling really good.
When they're feeling really lousy and stressed
and when they're feeling really good.
They've been sober for five years.
We hear about this in the news,
usually from celebrity examples,
people have been doing great,
all of a sudden they're back in treatment.
And you're like, what happened?
What happened was the dopamine circuit from other things
maybe a great life event or things are going well
or stress, the loss of a job, everything crashing,
puts our visual system
and the rest of our brain into a myopia.
We become near, we literally become near-sighted
and the dopamine system says
that's the only thing that's gonna get me
out of the mode that I'm in.
They literally don't see the other possibilities.
So some of the work that I'm starting
to get involved in now is to try
and inform the addiction treatment community,
the trauma community, that there are ways to use action
in the body to move people out of states of myopia,
near-sightedness.
And this is kind of a cognitive near-sightedness,
and allow them to start pursing
their time perception differently.
It hard, you know, it goes right back to time perception.
When an addict needs something,
their sense of time is fixed to the retrieval of that thing
or the, you know, reaching that thing.
And then when they can dilate their sense of time,
they realize they have time for other options,
but until you can dilate that,
there's really no chance, frankly.
You can't find a way in.
You can't find a way.
You can tell somebody you're gonna lose your kids,
and they'll do it anyway.
And that just tells us we need another route to it.
And so one of the things I think is powerful is to think
about how can we leverage the visual system?
How can we leverage the diaphragm system?
In the same way that you would tell a, you know,
somebody who's in, you know, has cancer
or needs a surgery of a certain sort,
like we need to leverage certain technologies.
Well, we need to leverage certain inborn technologies
of respiration and vision to be able to access states
of mind that will allow us to make better choices.
For the addict in that really near-sighted view fixated,
there is no other choice.
And I think those early years of skateboarding and being
you know, feral, it showed me that these, the people I knew
that became addicts and frankly, I know some adults
who have become addicts, even who have very quote-unquote
functional lives, it wasn't just them,
those people, you know, we like to think
they're making a bad choice and they had,
they're making a bad decision.
It's unclear to me whether or not they have a choice
in those highly myopic states of mind.
And so what we need to do is we need to dilate
their perception of the world around them.
We need to dilate their perception of time.
We need to learn.
They need to learn how to relax themselves
so they can actually see other options.
And it all relates to how the visual system
and the breathing system relate to autonomic function.
Addiction is the perfect sort of laboratory
to do this, and it's so important, I think,
because if it were simply the case that people just
needed family support and which they do, and they needed
you know, encouragement and they need discouragement
about making the wrong behaviors, then this,
we wouldn't even
be having this discussion.
It's so much
more complicated than that.
It's so much more complicated.
I mean, the thing, I think all of those are,
you know, really powerful tools and important things
to look at with respect to the addict mentality
or that disposition.
There has to be a level of self-awareness in that addict
that the decision to pick up the drink or to use the drug
begins so far in advance of the actual behavior.
By the time they actually pick up that drink,
there's no getting in the way of that.
Like that decision has so much momentum
behind it that it's almost impossible to reverse.
So a breathing technique or any technique
at that juncture is unlikely to be successful.
So it's about recognizing, you know,
when that state is starting to shift in that direction
whether it's days or hours or weeks
before the behavior choice to intervene at a place in time
when you can actually have an impact.
I agree.
I think that it's always an uphill battle with addiction
at least at first, but even just given
that the numbers on relapse, you know, I think every
what was it that someone wants told me?
I don't know if this is actually true,
but for most people, but he said,
a recovered addict told me, you know, he
that everyday he tells himself, no matter how far I drive,
I'm always the same distance from the ditch, you know?
I mean, the addiction community has-
There's so many awesome.
There's so many great takeaways, yeah.
What's interesting is there's a, some verbiage
around the yoga community that is very valuable.
I can't recall it off the top of my head,
but they talk about the great support that one can get
from learning to access brain states of timelessness, sleep
being very restorative, wakeful, deliberate disengagement
being very restorative, maybe meditation,
maybe through yoga nidra, maybe through simple,
quick breathing techniques, but being able to dilate
and contract one sense of time and not being locked
to one kind of space-time regime, the ability to recognize
that I'm not seeing clearly
or I see what I see, but I don't know what I don't see,
the ability to introduce that understanding
for somebody can be very powerful.
And I think we need to give them tools
that they can look to very quickly.
I don't think we're ever gonna have a treatment
for addiction that's in the form of a pharmaceutical,
like one pill,
because if you start tapping
into the dopamine system itself,
you start degrading other aspects of life.
So I think one of the reasons why addiction treatment
is so complicated is that you need many elements,
but the elements that come from the person themselves
are ultimately the most important ones, of course.
And I think physiology and neuroscience does have some tools
that can lend support to that.
Yeah, yeah, it's interesting.
I mean, I think that every couple of years
you see new science emerge on addiction
and there's some new protocol and, you know
12 steps constantly getting thrown under the bus
and, you know, 12 steps, what got me sober,
and I'm very rooted in that community.
I remain open to other, you know, modalities and protocols
and super interested in seeing where all of this is going,
but I think it is important to appreciate how complex it is.
Like there's a trauma element to it.
There's a, you know, behavioral modification element to it.
There's an emotional, like how do you,
how do you find a way to anchor this person to a path
a life path that has meaning and purpose
and all of these things inform this complex, you know,
soup that's going on in their head, that's dictating
whether they're gonna pick up a drink or not?
Yeah, and you know and I love the neuroscience community
with, you know, it's been my family
and home for many years now.
And the people working on addiction are, you know,
motivated from the right place.
And they are, you know, working exceedingly hard.
There are a lot of data now that show,
you know, for instance, there are complete genetic changes
in the cells that can, you know,
and the pathways that control dopamine and reward.
And that's all wonderful to understand.
But meanwhile, I think there are enough tools out there
that they need to be aggregated in a way that's structured
and that addiction treatment communities can leverage.
One of the things that would be of great use
is the idea of a biomarker.
So you described that, you know,
and it's really a beautiful example of how when some,
early on you might be able to intervene,
but later it gets much harder.
We need biomarkers that are gonna tell us
for some people or their family, that somebody is at risk.
Some of you have biomarkers-
Some kind of whooped device, right?
Well, I think it's gonna come from once you know
how well somebody is regulating
their own autonomic nervous system,
you can predict pretty well whether or not
they're going to succeed or fail in making good decisions.
And so I do think a whoop type device
or other sensor device could be tremendously beneficial
in detecting and telling people
whether or not they are veering off course.
Right.
And I think-
It's getting very minority report though.
It is, I mean, I think machines are gonna help us
make a lot of decisions
that we're actually pretty poor at making.
But the simplest of those that we might see
in the next two or three years is saying, look,
you've been working extremely hard on your book.
You're doing very well, but you're gonna need an extra hour
of sleep, I mean,
that's essentially what it's doing for you, or-
In 12 hours you're gonna make a bad decision.
or even cuing it, or insert might in there, right?
You might make a bad decision so that you're more aware
and you're gonna devote a little more mental energy
to the kinds of decisions you're making.
I think that as I pull a lot of all nighters and I still do
unfortunately in my career writing grants and so forth.
And I have this rule that I learned,
my gosh about 15 years ago which is I don't trust
any of my thinking that occurs between 3:00 AM and 7:00 AM
if I've been up all night, I just don't trust it,
because I start to think the world's falling apart.
I start thinking the word the is misspelled.
I mean, I really know I'm sleep deprived when words
like the look misspelled
and then I'm like, what's going on?
That's that duration, path, outcomes circuitry
starting to try and starting to fall apart.
So I think that that's an extreme example
but I think that short of having people buffer their lives
with tons of activities
and perfect nutrition and perfect social interactions,
people learning to control their autonomic nervous system,
I think is really the next step in our species evolution.
I really believe that what we are seeing now in the world
is a call to arms, if you will, or a request
from mother nature to have everybody learn
how to control their autonomic nervous system
a little bit better or ideally a lot better.
Yeah, it's absolutely critical, I think.
I mean, right now, you know, irrespective of what's going on
with the pandemic and the political climate,
and the protests and all the upheaval that we're seeing,
as a culture, we're experiencing an extraordinary poverty
of attention and focus.
We're so distracted by our devices.
We're more anxious and stressed
and depressed than we ever have been before.
This is not going in a good direction.
And to the extent that we can commandeer
a little bit more control over these things and understand
that we have some level of agency
and we can reverse this sort of automatic pattern
that we're on of just scrolling endlessly and, you know,
doing what we're doing that we know is not leading us
in a good direction is critical
if we're gonna find our way forward.
And to speak a little bit to what's going on right now,
I think, you know, and it's related,
and I'm interested in your thoughts on, you know,
the neuroscience that is, you know,
I think relevant to this is that we've lost the ability
to have civil discourse.
There's a real breakdown in communication right now,
culturally and socially, and it's fractured our society
and it's not good, right?
So what is going on neurologically
with human beings that are attaching themselves
and it's so self identifying with certain narratives
that it's polarizing our population and preventing us
from being able to just be together or united
or agree upon what is true and what is not true
and share a value system so that we can see our way
through the challenges that we're facing right now,
which many of which are an existential threat
to the future of humanity and the planet.
It's a huge problem, you articulated it beautifully.
And I think neuroscience can offer a couple of insights
into why it's happening
and perhaps what we might do about it.
So, one of the scientific results that I'm very intrigued by
is in the 1960s, a guy named Robert Heath recorded
from the human brain, there are people
you can't do this experiment nowadays,
but skull popped off, my neurosurgery friends tell me
that's no big deal, electrodes lower deep into the brain,
all over the brain and people can stimulate
wherever they want
and they just report what they're feeling.
So press one lever, they feel drunk.
They press another lever, they feel happy.
They press another lever, they feel sexually aroused.
And they're reporting all of this, right?
When was this done?
In the 1960s, the early 1960s.
Several times actually, and published twice
essentially the same data, different populations
in the journal science which is sort of our Super Bowl
science and nature cell, those are the big ones,
journals rep that is,
so the number one brain area that people want to stimulate.
They finally hit this lever where they go, oh, I like that.
And they just keep hitting that thing and hitting that thing
and hitting that thing, frustration and mild anger.
And I saw that result.
That's the choice.
I could be drunk, I could be happy.
I could be, I'm gonna choose frustration and anger.
Exactly, it's, what that told us is it's clearly tapped
into the dopamine reward system.
It feels like a hit of dopamine to them,
more than anything else.
So, we need to put that on the shelf and keep it visible
as we kind of march into this sort of answer
to your question.
The other thing is an understanding that,
and there's some recent data on this
that are really impressive, not from my lab
but from another lab, which is that beliefs
and information that supports our prior beliefs,
also increases the activity of these reward systems.
So the more I see stuff that verifies what I already think
or feel that they are bad and they are good
or that we are good and they are bad,
the more dopamine and adrenaline is released into my system.
Which we now know from our discussion a few minutes ago,
changes the way I view the world.
It actually changes the way I view the world.
It means that I'm gonna see certain things
and not see others.
And this also relates to the auditory system.
I'm gonna hear certain things and not hear others.
The things that verify my beliefs
are I'm gonna feel rewarded for,
the things that are counter to my beliefs,
I'm not gonna be it's rewarded for.
So we have all these barricades
to empathy and to really listening
and to really hearing what the other side is trying to say.
And we have all these support networks
in our body and our brain
which are building a bigger and bigger divide.
Now that's all very depressing.
So the question is, what's the boat
that's gonna get us across that divide.
And I believe, and I am not just defaulting to this
'cause it's what my lab works on,
but I fundamentally believe
that the boat that's gonna get us to the other side
is our ability to control our internal state,
to be able to ratchet down our level of autonomic arousal,
just enough so that I can dilate not just my vision,
of what's happening in my immediate environment,
but I can dilate my cognition, my thinking,
to the possibility that there may be a kernel of value
in what somebody else is saying, even if it's about me,
and I don't like what I'm hearing.
Now, as somebody who spent time
in the addiction treatment community, you probably know,
this is a lot of what you get good at as you learn to move
through something that to you feels very good and you know
all the reasons why it would probably be good to change it,
but you know what you don't want to,
because it feels so good.
So we're talking about an addiction to entrenched thinking.
We're talking about an addiction and neurochemical systems
that support, lack of change my refusal to change,
and stubbornness.
And I actually think just like in, for the treatment
of addiction and trauma, the key is to get people to learn
to tolerate progressively higher levels of stress,
and maintain dilation of sensory experience,
of thought experience.
We've got to create some small little portals
through which information can come in.
A lot's been made of mirror neurons.
I hate to break it to the crowd, but the data in support
of mirror neurons in humans is not that impressive.
And now the mirror neuron people are gonna come after me,
but fine.
There are circuits in the brain
that control emotional contagion.
And those are what's powerful.
My ability to recruit you into stress is much more powerful,
than my ability to recruit you into empathy
for something good.
That's a well-established neuro-biological fact.
Or empathy for someone's perspective
that you know, that I'm fundamentally
going to disagree with.
Right, so I think there are three gates to getting there.
And by there, I think we're, you know,
I'm referring vaguely to the idea
that we need to increase our level of understanding
at least our level of discourse
so that we can hear other really hear other people's ideas,
even though we don't like the way it feels,
and we love the way that we feel.
This is one of the results, so we love the way we feel.
We don't like the way other people feel.
The first thing is to bring the level of urgency
that we feel internally down.
We need to learn to calm ourselves
in order to really have the information start to come in.
Now, the system right now, and people out there
everyone's in a frenzy and you can see it, our collect
the collective consciousness is kind of losing its mind.
It's kind of out of its mind.
We need to learn how to turn off those amygdala circuits.
So are we all gonna get together and do EMDR?
Probably not.
Are we all gonna get together and do breathing exercises?
Probably not, not at scale.
What we need to do is start to figure out how we can,
I think, especially for the next generation of kids,
how to teach them to regulate their nervous system,
so that they recognize that pulse of adrenaline
as placing them in a compromised position.
Like we have to leverage the idea that being able to hear
and listen, hinges on the ability to be calm.
So therefore the ability to be calm is crucial to hearing
and listening and hearing and listening is crucial
to our advancement as individuals and as groups.
The problem is everyone's been trying to do this backwards.
They've said we all have to get along.
We have to cancel, cancel culture.
We all have to, you know, listen to one another.
And I think, again, we have to start from the inside.
We have to teach it physiologically.
Now I don't have a master plan on how to do that,
but one of the reasons I'm here
and one of the reasons I'm teaching neuroscience
on Instagram and not just in my laboratory is,
until we can learn to regulate the self,
I don't think we're gonna get where we wanna go
as a culture.
I think it really does start
with our own individual ability to do that.
And so, you know,
David's a really good example for instance,
of somebody who learn how to deal with his own internal mess
and build something beautiful out of that.
And he continues to do that.
And everyone's got to find that process for themselves
and whether or not you have a perfect family,
or whether or not you consider yourself the most inclusive
and accepting person in the world or not,
everyone needs to learn how to do that for themselves.
And everyone thinks we do it pretty well,
but I think it's clear that none of us do it well enough.
So, autonomic arousal, autonomic arousal, autonomic control.
I think those are the entry points for addiction,
for trauma, and for really impact that hearing
and listening, and until we do that
I think our species is gonna continue to go
around this merry-go-round where every 50
or a hundred years we crash
right up against the same general set of issues,
only now social media has made it slightly more,
or a lot more complicated.
It's a little bit similar to what you were talking about
in terms of the seeking external validation,
versus finding it within yourself.
Like essentially the protocol,
the prescription that you just gave has a strain of Buddhism
in it, in the sense that the world's gonna change
when we change ourselves.
Like the best, most impactful way
that you can make a difference for the world,
is to focus on being the best version of yourself.
How can you comport yourself in a way
that allows you to be more receptive,
and objective and empathetic and able to listen and hear?
And I think that's true, it's a hundred percent true.
And then I think about the person losing their shit
and, you know, target or whatever
over the masks or whatever, you know,
insane video clip of the day,
I happened to see on social media.
And I think we're doomed, like,
is this person gonna do that?
No, I can't control that, I can only control myself.
And I worry that when the onus is on the individual
to solve the problem, that,
that we're not gonna find our way through it, right?
Like we obviously need organizational, institutional,
and systemic changes.
We need to change the way these social media platforms work,
the way in which we're delivered information
and the way in which we're siloed,
but I don't have any control over any of those things.
The only thing I have control over
is my own internal mechanism.
So what other choice do we have?
Well, I think we need people in positions of power
and leadership who are very good at internal control.
You know, I think emotions are great.
I experienced them often intensely, but-
Congratulations.
Thank you.
They're not always wonderful to experience,
but I think it's clear that the level of autonomic arousal
that's associated with emotion's either very high
or very low, very happy or very sad, very anxious
or very angry, clouds our judgment.
It's very clear and I think the sooner-
We give them too much credence too,
they're just feelings, man.
Like we don't have to allow them to overtake us
and monopolize everything that we do.
They were designed to push us
along certain behavioral paths,
but they've grown in importance in the last few years.
And, you know, we could get into a discussion about how,
you know, social media marketing are designed to capture
these very deep limbic aspects of ourselves,
and they are, but what's amazing is and important is
that everybody has a forebrain.
Some people, it seems it's more developed than others,
but everybody has one.
And we have this capacity for what we call top down control
which is the ability to intervene in our own feeling states
and our own action states and to set some rigor
and some real clear marks that we're out to achieve.
And I think it's gonna start with the generation
that's very plastic right now.
You know, most parents are afraid of stressing their kids
because they don't wanna, you know, again, I went
to a high school where kids literally at Gunn High School
in the last 10 years, kids have, you know,
there've been over a dozen, you know, train track suicides.
So those are kids that are committing suicide
for different reasons, but a lot of them
is 'cause they just feel too much pressure.
So obviously we can't, you know, we can't pressure kids
beyond their capacity to regulate.
But the idea that all of our internal state
should be driven by external things,
that's a foolish misstep also.
So, I think we need to operationalize
what we're gonna teach the next generation.
You know, maybe our generation isn't really rescueable,
but maybe the next generation is.
And if they understand that there's some concepts
that sound a little mushy, like gratitude,
or mindfulness or these kinds of things, but as long
as they understand that, for instance, gratitude,
which we didn't really touch on,
involves a whole other neurotransmitter reward system
in the brain, the serotonin system, which buffers us
against injury, it can improve wound repair,
it can allow us to lean back
into these high stress regimes, learning
and kids learning how to toggle their nervous system
back and forth between highly, you know,
duration, path, outcome focus states of trying to improve
and learn and then learning how to really relax
and chill out and enjoy and be socially connected,
because it will allow them to ratchet back in,
and focus with extreme depth.
I think in doing that,
we might not get every child to learn how to do that,
but if we can distribute that information widely enough
and there's so many brilliant examples
and beautiful example, yours, David's, many others
of people that have been able
to tap into those systems intuitively,
if we can get that information out there,
I really believe that at least a subset of those kids
will grow up to be the leaders that our species really needs
in order to get through this next filter.
And right now we're feeling the stringency of that filter.
And I think our level
of autonomic dysregulation as a species,
the fact that we're there, we're here right now says,
okay, here's the task.
Are you guys gonna figure yourselves out?
You got this forebrain, my dog doesn't have
the forebrain I've got, he can't figure it out,
but we can work this out.
And it'll involve technologies,
like devices to measure how we're doing,
maybe some machines to guide that,
that's a different discussion,
but I think it's entirely possible.
And I think that's the evolutionary pressure
that we're in right now.
And I think that the next generation,
if they can hear about it and learn about it,
is gonna meet that demand.
Our species has done it for every other demand.
I toggle back and forth between extreme optimism
and, you know, dystopian despair.
Because on the one hand, you know,
you described the experience of going to therapy
and you know, how that was kind of, you know,
novel at that time, but we're not in that place anymore.
And everybody's got a smartphone and there's, you know,
head space and calm and waking up
and all these incredible apps
and mindfulness is part of the mainstream modern vernacular.
Like these kids are growing up,
not only aware of these practices, but amenable
and you know, they're, it's being done in the households
in which they're being raised,
which I find to be, you know, that's an amazing thing.
I think there is a consciousness that is emerging
out of these young people that hopefully, you know,
we can rely on to solve some of these problems.
And then, you know, I just think about the endless scrolling
and the associated, you know, I'm just like,
oh yes, we're fucked.
Well, I think it's clear that most people, young or old,
are content to be passive consumers
and spend out their dopamine doing
essentially meaningless activities,
and consuming food and consuming air
and light that is basically damaging to themselves.
And they, I don't think they care.
I think there are species let's be fair, our species is-
Non-essential.
Well, no, no, I didn't say that.
our species, although sometimes I think it'd be interesting
if some other species ran the earth
but we're the curators of the planet.
So I think that our species is probably divided
into those that are really going to try
and maximize on this gift of neuroplasticity, right?
We're the only species that has neuro-plasticity
throughout the lifespan and that neuroplasticity
in childhood lasts as long as it does as a function
of our total lifespan, it's incredible.
So we were gifted this and I think some people leverage it
and take advantage of it and other people don't.
And I think we need to accept
that we're not gonna get everybody,
but what we need to do is attach the reward systems
of society, financial, socio-economic, et cetera
to the kinds of behaviors that are
is gonna give rise to people that can lead us
into the next hundred years, 200 years.
Now that is not saying, oh do away with monetary systems,
actually the opposite.
I think that once people start to realize
that you're high performing military elite, military
your high performing athlete,
your high performing academics,
you're high-performing business people,
they actually have practices that they use
to regulate themselves to in order to
not just perform better, but sleep better
and not just to sleep better, but to listen better,
not just listen better but incorporate ideas that allow them
into states of creativity and states of mind
that really lead to new and exciting ways
that humans can interact.
And the many people will just be consumers of everything
they produce.
Well, all of the, what's what's great about new media
is that we've democratized access to this information.
And we're able to realize that these people
are not just freaks of nature
but that they have a methodology,
and they've created this canon, this tool kit
and these practices are available to everybody.
And you have people like David who are explaining this
in very plain terms, that it is within your power
to take advantage of these things,
to take better control of your life.
And we've never seen anything like that before,
in the history of humanity.
And I think that, that, you know,
that bodes well for the empowerment of the next generation
as well.
I do too, I, as you can probably tell,
I'm optimistic, I have to be,
because otherwise I can't justify the work that we're doing
but I think that there's so much interest now
in psychology and the brain and the self
in physical fitness, which, you know,
I think it's fair to say is inextricably linked
to mental fitness.
And the fact that people are so curious
about what other people are doing
and what are the paths to success and you know,
what are the resources for trauma and addiction?
I think there's been a kind of swarm of information.
It's been hard to sort through,
but I think 2020 is our, you know, is our sort of call
I keep calling it a call to arms,
and I, 'cause I guess I do feel that way.
It's very serious, this is serious business
and this is the time for us and the next generation
to step up and, you know, and to lead people
toward a place where we can function better
and where the next generation
will reflexively function better.
That's that beauty of early childhood is that
if some of this stuff is taught and passed off,
it's not gonna be perfect, but there'll be a generation
of people coming up, that will naturally understand
stress and agitation is taking them off their game
and leading to bad decisions
and will make the appropriate adjustments.
And there are people that will that read David's book
and your book, and we'll see the possibility
of doing something differently with a terrible childhood
or a brutal addiction.
And, you know, I think we need more stories of success.
I think it's easy to look out there
and see all the things that are going wrong
and we need to keep paying attention to those,
but we need these beacons that draw people forward.
And I say that from a place of experience, I mean,
I used to have to find it in books in the bookshelf.
I, there was no online back then or in mentors and you know,
you have to forage, you know, I think kids,
they have to have that foraging capacity.
They can't just sit there and wait for it to rain on them
or for a parent to dump it on them.
But I trust that they're out there
and that they're gonna figure it out.
Just like you're doing on Instagram.
You're dropping these videos basically every day, right?
Like more or less little lessons on neuroscience.
I'm trying, I'm trying to show people
that I have a kind of no acronym rule.
So I don't like embedding things
in a lot of complex language.
Sometimes I have to use an acronym, but yeah,
teach people a little bit about how their brain works
how it interfaces with psychology.
Everyone's got different goals and purposes in the world
but you know, that scientists are normal people
and that hopefully science has something,
I think really science has something to offer,
but it's not gonna happen if I'm vaulted in my lab
where my papers are read by the 12 people that care enough
to read the papers start to finish.
So I'm doing it, there are others out there.
Of course, David St Clair is doing it,
(indistinct) doing it.
I'm trying to recruit more people
from the scientific community to do this.
I think it's our responsibility.
You paid for it, it's your tax dollars.
You know, there's a tremendous cost to doing science
that is not often discussed
but I don't really consider it an option.
I consider it my obligation and I'm gonna keep going.
Well, keep doing it, man.
I appreciate the work that you're doing.
I think it's really important work.
We need it now more than ever.
And it's cool that you're getting out there
and sharing your wisdom with everybody.
It's super empowering, so thanks man.
Appreciate it.
Thank you.
Really appreciate the chance to be here.
If you're digging on Andrew
best way to find him is-
Huberman Lab.
Instagram.
Yeah, Huberman Lab.
Huberman Lab, cool.
All right, man.
Coming back, I made all these notes
all this stuff I wanted to talk to you about.
We got through like 10% of it, so
come by and talk to me again.
My apologies.
I realize you're pretty verbose.
Yeah, I just was getting out of the way man,
to, you know, listen to what you have to say.
I appreciate it, thanks man.
Thank you.
Peace.